videos boom it would live ladies and
gentlemen Charlamagne tha God my man
Andrew Schultz yes being here thank you
my god I've been a fan of yours for a
while you I think you're the last great
radio host and you will be the last
famous radios because I think radio a
flying thing you're the last great one
you're the you're the one who made a
famous from radio who [ __ ] out yeah in
this era I mean yeah I think radio is
like one of those uh one of those rare
lanes where it's really not a lot of
people who prosper in it yeah you know I
mean like I don't think about especially
in the black radio space I mean you've
got the Tom joiners the Doug banks to
Wendy Williams yeah you know so it's
rare in that Lane but I think I think
you've got people that have established
good careers and ya know but has a great
question when it was the last one he's
the last one person to become famous
from radio Bobby bones Bobby bones oh
that's nice I don't know who that is
I'm sure he's great even nationally
syndicated radio but he's on the country
stage he just want America wanna dance
with the Stars oh okay yeah I'm not I
don't give somebody only no Bobby B as
you talk about him really yeah yeah he's
got two national New York Times
best-selling book season that's one of
those things though it's like comedians
like you know you talk about a comic
that everybody loves and people like I
never heard of em like amongst comics
she's expected yeah Bobby host on Idol
now okay yeah then we were on the same
age so I would have to give it I would
have to put him in that fine you and Bob
you're a gracious man yeah in my opinion
you're the Last Samurai guys like you I
just want to snatch you up and bring you
over to podcast like get the [ __ ] out of
there get out of that censored bossman
world no it's interesting with podcast
together the brilliant idiot you know we
you know pod track right yeah sure sure
like we just cracked five track The
Breakfast Club he's number 20 on Padre
okay so you put that online as well yeah
we put it out of the park that's it cuz
I feel like with radio that's what it is
like people still listening to
terrestrial radio black you have to go
where the people are so you have the
podcast you
to have the YouTube following like you
can't wait for people just to come to
radio ever I wish you could swear though
so that's the proper thing he city they
release all the interviews they do on
Breakfast Club and those things explode
yeah you can they have all the curse
exactly that's where most people
globally yeah would watch and listen I
mean right yeah that's what separates
this radio this era of radio from other
eras of radio like Howard Stern didn't
have YouTube you know saying if I was
third at YouTube wouldn't be no question
he'd still be the [ __ ] guy me
even though he is the guy right but he'd
still be like super super the guy in
this air ride he's in that paywall which
is very strange a serious paywall that's
the strangest pay well yeah yeah he took
the check but then you get financial
independence man act why is the pre-chat
let's be realistic
he's already financially independent so
why didn't do it he just the numbers
they're thrown at him yeah that was a
difference three hundred million right
well I think that was just initially it
I think he makes like a hundred million
every year something crazy so three
hundred was flat and then another 100
and then what stars I got the differs
between like your kids beings creating
like your great great great grandkids be
history right yeah but serious stock in
seriousness means like blockbuster stock
yeah
I remember when Netflix used to have
those DVDs that you would get like front
of the [ __ ] surrett Mafia the box
you have to send them back now I was so
funny I was home this weekend I was in
Moscow in South Carolina and like there
was a Black Panther DVD from the library
and my mom's house I'm like what it's
like Panthers in the original Black
Panthers or I was like yo she was true
from back in the day okay that's an
original black who got the Black Panther
DVD that they checked out from the
library and have not bought it back yet
you didn't bring it back to the library
yeah now you don't have to like what are
they really gonna do why are we mad the
Black Panther from the library
cuz you didn't wanted it and it was
there and you were at the library I'm
still trying to understand why you
called library what is it library I
don't [ __ ] know my name graduate god
Barry it's like library yeah it's one of
those words yeah you know but everyone
even like George Bush when he was
president would say expecially yeah
exactly yeah
yeah I think a lot of it have to do a
reason because I still say straight
street strong okay yeah screech screech
bro specifically everybody knows then
it's fun that's the point if you had a
person say I can wrap them right it's a
way to dick well it's like dialects like
my grandparents were from Sicily and
they would talk in dialects and even
people that knew Italian would know what
the [ __ ] they're saying yeah like just
like people that knew pure Italian it's
some weird like Pig Latin type [ __ ] yeah
you know I mean my mom Scott it's like
if you listen to real Scottish people
talk you don't understand what the [ __ ]
they're talking
oh that with that accent so stirred the
way they roll their words together thick
and then they get them drunk oh it's
impossible were you from Joe I was born
in New Jersey and I grew up mostly in
Boston but most really all over the
country a lot of sovereign sensibilities
like before we started the podcast he
was talking about all the hunting
hunting that you I didn't get in
until 2012 Wow why because I was
thinking about being a vegetarian I was
like I I was watching these animal
rights videos like he to videos and I
was like I don't want to participate in
this factory farming [ __ ] it just it's
[ __ ] up you watch these pigs slammed
into these cages together and cows and
chickens I was like this is inhumane
right decided to glad I thought killing
them yourself I decided one of two
things either I was gonna I was gonna
try hunting and either I was gonna
become a vegetarian or husband gonna
become a hunter and so I became a hunter
I did it I killed a deer I ate it I was
like this is perfect I love this make
sense well you saw that it was inhumane
for the animal to be dying no no I want
to kill them factory farming farming not
that there look every animal dies they
don't live forever become angels they
live in the wild when you hunt you dip
your feet into the wild you go out there
and you're fair chase you'll find them
you track them you stay downwind you get
in a good position you kill them and
then you eat them right and it's a
different animal again when you're
eating that like I eat an elk steak I
know
note that it's delicious yeah I know
that I was there
can I see a picture I'm still trying to
imagine what it is because I understand
dear and I understand moose a giant deer
it's that those antlers elders on like
an 800 pound animal how tall is it it's
huge
they're big like six feet Oh taller yeah
yeah elk and mushrooms moose is crazy I
said the first time I saw a moose it was
like that scene in Jurassic Park or Jeff
Goldblum looks out the Jeep and yeah
dinosaurs like you can't believe how big
a moose it yeah I don't think I've seen
a moose in person I'll top of an elk to
double the size of an oh yeah yeah we
need to go hunting man you want to go
I'm being camping and hunting where it's
one or the other well you could do both
okay well you be drawn dude well you
could camp or you could hunt rather and
then stay in a nice Lodge that's the
move
yeah but also you know I kind of want to
do like the full outdoor yeah because
sometimes I watch those shows on like
Nat Geo or something like that and it's
they're just living off the land and
they gotta like make up or make a yurt
you know you make it out of snow yeah
don't do that don't do that no but what
if like two days like a cool you want
you what you want it's like a
real tent with a real sleeping bag stay
warm and you're healthy and you're not
worried about [ __ ] freezing to death
or anything weird like that yeah and
make sure you have water filter so you
could drink out of a stream if you
really want to do that yeah yeah you
should try letting in New York like
nobody's ever done that like you can
hunt rats think about all the big-ass
rats in New York I'm not gonna lie
you'll probably get a lot of attention
from back in the day you could go 200
25th Street and like Spanish Harlem and
you could buy pigeons people were like
catching pigeons and they were selling
them and trying to front like they were
exotic pigeons [ __ ] I swear to God
you know pigeons were brought over here
for food that's what squab is what the
[ __ ] is quite squab is like a like a
bougie restaurant item and it's actually
young pigeons really yeah that's what
that's what squab is yeah I didn't know
that all pigeons all pigeons you see in
the United States or all brought in from
somewhere else for food and then they
released and become feral they're like
the wild hogs of the bird world what a
young rats called better youthful food
it's a good question do who uses young
rats for food I don't know but there's a
concept that rats documentary no this is
just the dogs that hunt rats in New York
oh yes I don't believe that [ __ ] what do
you mean you don't believe that they're
really guys sending their dogs out to go
get rats oh they are for what there's so
many souls yeah I guess I mean they're
not gonna fix it there's no way to fix
it but like Jack Russell Terriers they
[ __ ] rats up they're designed to [ __ ]
rats up but there's got to be people who
live up north in New York who have the
same desire to hunt they just go down
south so why not go right they hunt deer
New York has a lot of deer new jersey
yeah Jersey always got a lot yeah I live
in Jersey that's one of the reasons I
love joy because I I'm from Sauk Atlanta
so I'm used to seeing deer isn't possums
and just yeah different types of
wildlife running through the streets
that's why I like living in Jersey yeah
Jersey is an unusual pledgers he has
more black bears per capita than any
state in the United States I don't know
if that's a fact but I believe you cuz
I've seen it myself yeah they're
everywhere you seen bears on your
property not on my property but when I
used to us they were my aunt in the
Poconos
the Bears used to come in her backyard
cuz it was like a scream in the backyard
and it would like coming in and just
grab fish out of the screen they killed
a kid one bear killed the kid a couple
years ago from
the college's what good college it was
it the one near New Brunswick what was
it Rutgers you never seen a video in
Jersey at a walking bear debate I would
walk on two feet through people's
backyard like there it is look at it the
video the bear walking around oh yeah
okay that's a Bigfoot yeah that's it you
know who believes in Bigfoot yeah you
have a believer in the studio right now
who believes in Bigfoot do you really
yeah 100% but you know why I believe in
Bigfoot because of [ __ ] like mooses
species like a moose yeah some point in
life somebody was trying to explain that
to somebody like me get the [ __ ] out of
here right now when he's trying to
explain it to me look at the size of
that god yeah that's insane those legs
work they'll [ __ ] you up - there's the
those are the rare deer species that
will [ __ ] massive death yeah they
used to dealing with wolves if they
think you're a threat they just run up
on you and stomp you to death why don't
you believe in Bigfoot
well I actually did a television show
where I went hunting for them no no no I
did a show called Joe Rogan questions
everything we spent a whole week in the
Pacific Northwest talking to Bigfoot
hunters yeah we camped out there me and
Duncan Trussell went into Duncan
scientists and interviewed all these
different archaeologists all these
different people that didn't believe and
did believe it wasn't real animal at one
point in time yes I don't think it
exists now I think it existed it's just
a primate in the [ __ ] woods yeah okay
you don't think it exists oh I thought
you believed that it exists now I did up
to a certain point but I was like in
this era with all of the cameras and
everything else somebody would have
caught one okay yeah yeah I don't
believe it existed at some point but I
don't believe it exists I mean let me
tell you something Charlemagne has this
amazing power to manifest [ __ ] okay so I
see how it could lend itself when you
believe something so much it becomes
real right right I could see how it
manifests itself into things like
Bigfoot like you believe in things
I mean sasquatches well then it's not a
far-fetched idea
literally just a primate in the woods
I'm the same when you were young and you
believed that you were team wolf yeah
like he believed that his ears actually
changed shape no they did I was gonna
turn into this werewolf at lunchtime and
I was saying this for like a week
straight and we was all sitting at the
table and I was just sitting like it's
gonna happen actually around two points
all the kids at the table saw and jumped
up and ran so he [ __ ] up my
concentration so if I hadn't kept that
concentration going I probably would
have turned full-fledged werewolf in
that moment maybe levitated posture I've
done that before really oh yeah I said I
grew up double witness I used to leave
the kingdom Oh and I would walk outside
of the Kingdom Hall and I would like
jump in the air and be looking down at
the kingdom all and not stay up there
for a while and then I would come down
he's not doing bits right he really
believes this [ __ ] I'm just telling you
what happened in my life I don't know if
you believe it you believe it if you
don't you don't memories a strange thing
ah you think it's one of those like you
recreate the past
well memories a strange thing like you
you couldn't believe something and know
something to be true when it didn't
actually happen
mmm you can absolutely do that I mean
isn't what what you have people have
memories in their head that never
happened you have memories that people
positioned in your head they proven that
you can talk someone into a memory you
could change someone's memory as always
particular dangers for kids when you
know there's a whole case where they
were talking kids into saying that their
teachers molested them yeah and all
example like lost their careers lost
their lives turned out was all hot
percent made up but those kids believed
it they believed when they were telling
them that they were molested they
believed it yeah that's got anyway what
does that call when you give that
information to the police
what does it go when they like
interrogate you interrogations call me
borshu yeah they can worship yeah well
there's a whole articles reading the
other day about why people make false
confessions
why do they just get talked into believe
in the day or something scared the devil
you can't especially a young kid from
the hood and you like 15 16 years old
like yeah you went to jail for 28 if you
don't tell us what we need to know you
don't [ __ ] know no better yeah that
they put you under duress they put you
in a room they sit you across from a
position of authority in this person
questions you make you start you start
talking you start saying things that
aren't true you've seen beyond skits
great detail you gonna get 20 years and
get butt-fucked foot 15 of them so the
first five I mean they let you kind of
settle in for the first five yeah you
get nice and tight you might go in on a
criminal
monster when I was young I used to have
a red tractor trailer it was a red
plastic trailer with a farmer on top of
it and like when those hard plastic
trailers that farmer used to get off
that trailer and [ __ ] with me and I took
it in the yard when they put kerosene on
it and set it on fire and in my mind I
remember hearing that farm farmer scream
my mom would even tell you to start how
I like to always talk about how this
[ __ ] farmer used to come off with his
tractor and [ __ ] me and she saw me
set it on fire and I thought I was crazy
until years later I met Tiffany Haddish
and she said she had experiences where
her teddy bears used to come to life and
[ __ ] with her so I'm just saying mmm I'm
just saying [ __ ] happens all this really
happening and I haven't heard this story
happen at night
when's it happen oh I don't remember a
caramel I don't remember like the
details of when it was at night or
during the day that's one of those
things they're trying to figure out with
UFO abductions okay you know almost all
those UFO abductions happen while people
are sleeping and they think what's
happened is your brain is releasing
endogenous psychedelic chemicals and
it's forcing you to have these
hallucinations and that you really do
believe you're taken aboard these UFOs
and gone what if someone's watching you
with a camera nothing actually happens
questions people swear by it have you
ever had one of those dreams where it
feels as if someone's holding you down
that hag hags riding you really call it
a sleep paralysis but growing up in
South Carolina it would say the hag was
riding you okay what I saw is that you
would either put us either put a straw
broom at your door or you would take
salt and spring
salted your dog because when the Hagins
did you room you got to pick up every
kernel of salt so why the time he picks
up every kernel thought his [ __ ] date
what does a hag hag was like these
little old women that they say would
come ride people in the middle of the
night I think I've seen them before
but it really looks like just a shadowy
figure and it's the same feeling you get
definitely like still your body is
frozen I can't with your eyes are open
yes but you feel like you're talking but
nobody hear you that's what they say
that's the Hagrid what do they say that
is like what does scienter alysus yeah
the blood is not flowing in your body
looks like when you're sitting on the
toilet too long and your [ __ ] leg
your legs go yeah yeah I think it's a
psychological thing
thank you your your brain is just not
sending signals to your body but you
want to move and you just don't dude I
gotta move but I can't ya know that's
frightening I had that before and I've
had that before and I had when I woke up
it was just you seen the movie signs
yeah yeah so it was this creature that
looked like he was from the movie
science but it was purple in black and
it was standing over me and I couldn't
move and so I was making noises trying
to get it to go away and if the Sun came
up it just faded away now that I don't
know if it was a dream or an actual
visit from extraterrestrial it could be
the thing about extraterrestrials you
believe in it
well you know I believe in this well you
believe in everything the reality and
toys that can harass you as a child
there's there's no evidence but the
numbers of humans I mean the numbers of
planets rather that could support humans
they're they're pretty well just what
we've documented so far it's pretty
interesting just what they know about
the thousands of plans to discover
there's hundreds that could possibly
support human life and then there's
hundreds of billions of galaxies right
the idea that we're the only one not
only that neil degrasse tyson to explain
this to me is a mindfuck and a half that
the universe is so big that not only is
there another you out there that has
done everything exactly as you've done
to every pause mm-hmm like that pause
every pause down to the second yeah an
infinite number yeah yeah you're talking
about is it called the infinite in an
infinite universes there's this exact
conversation happening yet people look
exactly like that because infinity
implies and the
even in variations there's one when you
get up right now and you have to take a
piss right run out of the room or
Charlemagne's there you're there I'm
there there's one when you get a bag
that we don't believe you that you saw
Bigfoot or something you know that kind
of [ __ ] yeah this the idea that when you
think of infinity right we think about
its being really big it's not it's
impossible yeah to put in your head yeah
the infinite infinite universes like the
size of the universe 14 billion
light-years apart
infinite numbers of those not only that
they think that inside every galaxy is a
supermassive black hole and inside that
black hole may be another universe with
hundreds of billions of galaxies with
hundreds of billions of black holes
inside each one of those hundreds of
billions of galaxies hundreds of
billions of black holes that it's
fractal and that it's impossible for you
to even conceive yeah I think it's very
so you're saying just based on the
numbers there has to be something only
life in this book think well the only
life in the universe I'm just saying
like hmm whether or not it's reached us
it well yeah I don't think it's reached
us and if it has reached us it's like
they have to find a way to bend time
right time is the biggest issue no I'm
gonna tell you what the problem like
we're earthlings right yeah and if you
look at how diverse the earth is like
there's different species of [ __ ] in the
woods different races of [ __ ] in the
water different species of [ __ ] in the
jungle different species of [ __ ] in the
sky why wouldn't the earth be I mean the
universe be just as diverse yeah and
we're assuming shorter we're assuming
we're the smartest life form in the
universe no no I'm not at all
and sure it is all I'm saying is life
has an end right what is the the oldest
species on the earth right now where the
turtles lived like 200 as I'm sure like
then what so let's say it's 200-300
years right
let's say that's the max now we have 300
years to travel millions of light-years
away to get to another galaxy to see
other planets to see if they have some
[ __ ] and they have the same for us so
let's say there is another species did
somehow found a way to take your the
consciousness that they have and put it
in a robot that can then last for
thousands of years then they would have
the opportunity to come here but we're
limited by time right
you will die before you get
we're like we can go to Mars we can't
come back think we really I think we're
basing that off our intelligence there
might be a species in this universe that
can fly to earth the way we fly to LA
but that's what I'm saying they would
happen at any time not necessarily what
they could do is fold time or fold it
whatever you don't even create that
wormhole thing where you're going where
instead of it's not linear it's whatever
it's in some really time event horizon
they talked about how they did that
remember that movie yeah but and there's
another one too at Matthew McConaughey
oh yeah yeah interstellar yeah where
they get into like space-time space-time
is really interesting right it's like
the faster you go the less you age Yeah
right like so somebody's in a plane
colliders into someone here on the earth
right so some is flying around the earth
and a plane versus us sitting on earth
they will age for actually less right so
if you just increase their speed and
decrease ours when that or keep ours are
the same they will let's say not age at
all compared to us aging like 30 years
even crazier Brian Cox I want to see his
cosmos exhibit I mean that's the the
physicist oh he's a physicist okay from
CERN from the Large Hadron Collider yeah
yeah yeah podcasts and shows he said
that if you were born and right next to
you like your mother and you both put on
a watch at the moment you were born and
then you checked that watch 30 years
later if you have a perfect watch it was
never out of time your watch would have
a different time than her watch because
you have gone through time differently
than she has fraction I don't say that
fractionally because the amount of that
how fast you travel mm-hmm it you you
you experience time in a different way
the path you take in life the different
terrain you travel over the earth all
those factors play in to how much time
has passed let's say you live on the top
of a mountain and she lives at the
bottom you're actually traveling at a
faster rate right because it's no
different than like let's say there's a
ball on a tether right and you're just
swinging it around in a circle right the
ball at the end is actually going faster
than your hand in the middle swinging
around right so since you're going
faster actually aging slower and we're
talking about fractions of seconds yeah
but over the course of time it proves
that everyone experiences time to
slightly
different rate which proves Einstein's
theory that if you travel very fast in
the spaceship and then come back you
would look at your brother who was your
age and now he's a hundred years old and
you know thirty so I think I figured it
out how we can time travel or not time
travel but I think I figured out all
right now so we're trying to create ok
and again I don't know [ __ ] but this is
just me like you know this is brilliant
idiot [ __ ] right here ok so what we have
to do is go faster than the speed of
light in order time travel I don't know
how to do that just yet but what I think
we can do is we're trying to use like
rockets to propel us at a certain mile
per hour to get close to the speed of
light [ __ ] the [ __ ] the Rockets why
don't we use light as wind and create a
sail that harness light and that sail
will naturally take us the same speed or
as close as we possibly could get to the
speed of light they did in a movie
called sunshine I'm a [ __ ] genius
science fiction movie I'm talking to Bob
Lazar tonight that was the guy I was
telling you I wanted to bring you to
dinner I'm going to his well if you want
to go he's a guy who worked at area 51
and I didn't even know if we talked
about tomorrow yeah bring it up Oh area
51 is real but this guy literally worked
on what he says are alien spacecrafts
spacecraft that sail on sunshine could
be the next big thing bro you should
work for now Jamie this is public school
education get you a job at Trump space
for that's it I don't want to do any
other man I just want to throw the ideas
out there and I think I got it in mail
this is a legit space for shirt from
trumps from Trump Tower
Tim Dillard Bobby this yo shouts at Tim
I love Tim what the real [ __ ] space
force this is the logo that's all it do
you got from Target
that was [ __ ] goofy [ __ ] you had a
friend who works on alien spacecraft oh
I don't know podcast tomorrow and he
worked at area 51 is he allowed to talk
about that [ __ ] what are getting is
because he's been talking about it for
decades really yeah and they've tried to
discredit him there's a he's very
controversial a lot of people think he's
full of [ __ ] but the more II there's a
recent documentary by Jeremy Corbyn the
more you look at the documentary he
knows too many things he knows too many
things that that prove that he
absolutely worked at area 51 he got
arrested for bringing people to a
lookout peak to look over where the area
where they would launch these spaceships
and he's got video of these things
flying through the air doing all these
maneuvers that no conventional
spacecraft could do in 1980 whatever the
[ __ ] was were you gonna arrest it they
must have some type of like like like
NDA with extraterrestrials but they
don't talk about yeah I feel like the US
government is just governments in
general throughout the world have some
type of NDA yes we'll kill you I don't
know how pain is the same when Leonardo
DiCaprio uses on his girlfriend he's got
the greatest Indian history thinking but
now holy [ __ ] no one gives a [ __ ] about
India yo so we had to pay people and
they don't care they'll come out and
talk about it later they had a lot Lisa
Ann on the on the podcast right I just
parked a horn star yeah go flagrant to
right and Lisa Ann came on and she was
talking about NDA's and how stupid women
are for obeying them and I was like what
are you talking about and she's like
what do they have to lose they don't
have any money
exactly so she's like you have a bunch
of [ __ ] heels in your apartment you
think that Leonardo DiCaprio is gonna
take your heels you could break any
[ __ ] NDA but for whatever reason they
get scared you pay a woman half a
million dollars tell her to keep her
mouth closed she breaks the NDA in an da
says she has to pay you back exactly we
don't know money forever
what money everyone is Bill O'Reilly he
had to pay a lady thirty two million
dollars I mean there's no [ __ ] worth it
I need to see what she looks like
can we look at this one I need to see
some wild wild [ __ ] oh there's no
picture of this woman I don't I need to
see thirty two million dollars on blast
but
either love to I would love to see what
she looks like 32 million he agreed to
it he must have did something he didn't
want nobody be even remotely here's
gonna pecked they'll get Peck 100% get
is it's not even about what actually
happened is about what the person said
they did to you that can ruin your
reputation
she's got pics she's got video
something's going it guaranteed DNA
she's got his [ __ ] under her thumb nail
like guarantee that a guy like Bill has
to keep a certain like I guess you know
standard about himself right you have to
look at him a certain way in order to
listen to what do you think yes in order
to take his his information
you know correctly I guess seriously
yeah yeah so he could lose all that
equity in his audience he's out there
doing wild fantasy actually didn't help
them he's gone anyway is it over for
Bill well he's not on fox news anymore
he's podcast it was their number one guy
and they were like not worth it yeah
really got canceled yeah came over in a
big way yeah and I think he does do some
type of broadcasting now but nobody
cares well he that out a book and the
book was number one New York Times
bestseller he doesn't box yeah it
doesn't history books yes
you know like I don't even think he
writes him I think he just puts his name
I wonder about a guy like bill doe
because think about it like you started
your own platform you know I'm saying
and people really care about your voice
do people ever really care about Bill
that's the thing people do now but check
it right so it's like sometimes you
become a mouthpiece for a network or for
an ideology they believe in and this is
the difference this is how you find out
if people really [ __ ] with you the
second you leave that network it's like
when people leave your SPN and you never
hear about them is like oh you thought
you were bigger than ESPN Deportes they
just want you to say strike wall that's
it yeah so I think we learned that bill
really didn't have all that cachet that
we thought we had yeah that's why I like
yes PN is a good analogy that's why you
got to get people I skip bayless props
yes you got to give the Mel Hill props
they can go other places
they'll care about what they have to say
even if it's just in tweets right I
don't even know what Bill O'Reilly's
twitter handle is I imagine something
around like bill or I'm sure it is but
you know I see him
he's never known for like Oh Bill
O'Reilly said this on social media when
the last time you heard Bill O'Reilly
say so might not even be I made some
news yeah he may might not even be on
stuff bro yeah he's podcasting from his
like apartment or something like dude is
there's no background nothing really
yeah it's bad he's not even wearing like
suits shirt bro we gotta look him up we
got to see the girl he [ __ ] at him and
see how they're living right thank you
guys like that they say we'll just lay
low for a couple years and then someone
will scoop you up again now there's only
one Fox and when Fox lets you go yeah if
you're one of those guys those neocon
guys like you don't really have any
place else to go
and he's too old to really understand
the landscape of like how to navigate
this new internet space you got plenty
of conservative voices who don't have to
be platforms right the Candace on Tommy
Lauren's [ __ ] Perot I don't look at
them Wow no makeup
he's wearing a nurse's outfit underneath
that's on for sure guarantee that's dad
or shirt for real did that [ __ ] take his
wardrobes go no this is not good those
are nose watch the film fold no spin
news
nobody lo Riley comic know we need to
get some news on Twitter there are no
charges you are presumed innocent in
this file tree this is not what the left
wants what is this about what's rant
about if April night people maybe weekly
report scroll down how many people were
watching that
how many people have him on Twitter how
many how many followers do you know your
father was he had in that video had 500
maybe 1000 views can you look at him
right there in that video right now go
down now scroll down do you think he's
doing the orange thing to reflect
reverse on he's bringing him an white
look at that that's 100% the orange
thing perhaps he looks like turmeric
yeah but he don't look anything like you
look some real life that's like an
Instagram ho
wait a minute update your picture son
500,000 views yeah definitely watching
it but now he's in the vacuum but it's
those crazy old white people that live
in Kansas yeah but they don't happy
Witter a man a win is a win
yeah I'm saying if you got 580 thousand
people I can watch when you put up a
video and you can still get paid for it
I'm cool with that's true you know say I
think we put too much emphasis on like
whatever mainstream it is no there's no
such thing as manage people there's not
just one scream anymore right Nass over
that's why and shots a Brendan Schaub
that's why we wanted you guys to connect
because I feel like you guys represent
the most I think you will are both the
most influential people in media right
and you represent put that kind of
pressure on me pour it no because I
think you guys represent and I think the
illusion was before I went on before I
went on ever the first time the illusion
was that these things operated in
separate spheres right that there are
these different vacuums like the
Charlemagne world right and then the
rogen world and then I went on I found
all these people that knew me from our
podcasts they also listened to yours
right so it turned out in that moment as
a oh [ __ ] it's not as fractured as
people think now cuz everybody's aware
people always been hitting me for years
like yeah you gotta go on Joe Rogan you
gotta go juggling you gotta go on Joe
Rogan so it's just clearly that the
worlds collide it's all its
interconnected especially this internet
wave that were all right now the
Internet wave people are craving this
type of information they're craving the
type of interviews you guys are doing
and talking to the people you guys are
talking to right and I don't know for me
this is really cool just to see well
they like people like the fact that
everybody could do everybody show it's
not like like Jimmy Kimmel never does
like the Seth Meyers show but you know I
mean it's like yeah everything is not
that world is very disconnected
yeah whereas this world the internet
world is like like for the comics and
podcasts like there's no competition
everybody helps everybody everybody
supports it oh you love everybody I mean
that's one thing I've always noticed
about your platform like you've always
bought on up-and-coming comedians who
just needed that extra push to put
people to know who the [ __ ] they are you
know that's important that's why yam is
paddling yesterday genuinely funny
foursome is insane like you can only
take a story that's that in that tragic
and turn it into a sitcom she was
talking she's talking about her
ex-husband who shot her in the tendon in
the head shot her in the titty shot in
the back of the head shot edited he got
her pregnant
it was [ __ ] her when she was 12 got
her pregnant when she was 14 with two
kids by the time she was 16 she had an
abortion when she was 16 with with his
third kid she called him up to try to
get him to apologize to her he wouldn't
apologize to her so she forgave him and
she said it released like this huge
weight off of her shoulder she was
talking about it like you can't believe
her story she's laughing about of course
not yeah that whole forgiveness thing we
talk about that all the time I'm not
with that whole like I forgive you and
it makes me feel better I'm fine not
[ __ ] with you
I'm fine saying [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this
person like I can't forgive you when I
thought uh you know the Emmanuel movie
just came out you know the shooting that
happened in child in South Carolina and
like all of the family members forgave
Dylan roof and I'm like there's one dude
in there that's like [ __ ] him you killed
my mom yes yeah like that's a perfectly
fine emotion you yeah you go talk to
your therapist about it you allow
yourself to feel like yes [ __ ] him why
do we feel like we got to forgive you
know anyways comes off our shoulders
thank you for her it was like she was
carrying around our whole life you know
I think for her it just helped her and
she nude he was a piece of [ __ ] when she
was talking him she said to him like you
were [ __ ] me when I was 12 years old
and he literally said this to her your
mind your body wasn't 12 that's what he
said to her and she's just like so she
decided after that like I'm not gonna
invest my energy in this I'm gonna let
it go yeah let it go said she just
doesn't [ __ ] with him doesn't talk with
him she doesn't she doesn't carry around
the hate that was a it was poisoning her
yeah I get it and I understand the power
forgiveness there's a reason why it
exists right the reason why is you know
it's still here for thousands of years
this idea of hey let's forgive so that
we could feel better right I think I
think I think usually things get weeded
out if they don't work well it's hard to
forgive someone that doesn't feel bad
about what they did it's one thing if
you like man I [ __ ] up I'm sorry
please forgive me yeah like I get it
you're a person human beings make
mistakes I forgive you
yeah but someone is like you were you
were no you know you weren't 12 with
your mind your body he's talking about
[ __ ] you when you were 12 years old I
have an 11 year old daughter the idea of
a grown man [ __ ] her no we gotta go
huntin finally yeah yeah you might [ __ ]
him up and then after you [ __ ] him up
you be like you know what it's all good
so maybe forgiveness is like
misconstrued maybe you're not actually
forgiving the person and letting them
offer what they did but you maybe were
just removing them from your
consciousness people forgive when they
not gonna do [ __ ]
huge punches you in the face you Mike by
the way that's probably when I would get
to that point of forgiveness when you
want to do something to somebody so bad
but when you get the opportunity you
don't yeah and you realize it's that not
that important to you then at that
moment I might be like you know what god
bless ya I wish in the back when you
guys have like surpassed people in your
career that were pieces of [ __ ] to you
as you were coming up did did the anger
that you had towards them totally leave
your body
no absolutely hold on to that I need you
and by the way god bless you yeah but
the facts it affects yeah you did fire
me right no Boogedy from he does yeah
yeah they told him that if he if he
fired me and whatever he bought in
didn't work they was gonna send him back
to st. Louis yeah moved from st. Louis
to do betta PD in Philly and so he fired
me what he bought in didn't work right
and they kept their word and they sent
him copies probably best informed though
yeah but everything worked out for
everybody he's living a great life in
st. Louis I'm living a great life life
have you seen that a Jordan what is it
yeah what was it was he wouldn't stop
talking about journalists bro he
remembered every single thing and
allyce's he's Bernard Hopkins remember
remember no not as a fighter he needed
to be the villain he needed to be real
for the motivation y'all don't use that
y'all don't have people that [ __ ] in on
y'all and like you know when I surpass
them and not for me and what I surpass
them it goes away it's weird I mean I'm
not saying it goes away but I have to
remind you you told me I wasn't gonna
make you he'll tell you that when I was
when I was starting out as a comic and I
was you know it's rough in New York
[ __ ] [ __ ] too used to
carry a list of people who are pieces in
my wallet all the people I was gonna say
[ __ ] you to when I passed them and as I
would start to pass them
I felt zero I felt your anger I almost
start to feel bad yeah [ __ ] you're still
in the same place that's why you were
dick tamika's right I was all you had to
be addictive well that's the type of
person that is a dick to someone who's
coming up the person who's like it's
famine mentality yes you think there's
not enough yes so you try to keep people
away get away get away where's the
people that don't have famine mentality
like come on come on come on let's do it
money for everybody yeah yeah everybody
I don't have anger like if you like I've
been five four times from radio you know
what I'm saying is I'm not angry to
people that fired me but the people who
told me things like
like it was a guy named DJ Cavs and shot
the psychic liner who told me I wouldn't
went out my first time I got fired he
told I would never work in radio again
because I was an [ __ ] yeah and then
you know Boogedy told me this is why
you'll never make it in radio so those
two individuals just need to be reminded
people need to know that they may go
would you like to know the person that
cut Michael Jordan from the basketball
team yeah wouldn't you like to know the
person that didn't hire Oprah the
newscaster back there would you like to
know want to know I've had other
executives in radio you know like smooth
oh my god doc one is doc one has told me
that one person in particular he would
never hire because they fired me and
couldn't give him a reason why when he
asked him why it was like I just did I
just I didn't didn't like what he was
doing so he was like I never hired a
person so that's why certain people need
to be told in reminding about like a
strike it's great that you know the
difference is also that you get hired
for these jobs and you can get fired by
these [ __ ] yes and there's always
that weird power play between producers
and executives it happens with
television shows and networks and it
happens with radio it happens it's this
a power play yeah the thing about
comedies it's like you know you just
work at a different club there's no real
the only mean there's a little weird
struggle between you and the other
comedians but there's no where real
struggle between you and the club once
you go in there you sell out you kill
your friend everybody they don't give a
[ __ ] 100 percent here's your money bro
they [ __ ] care and it doesn't matter
how much of a diva you are everybody
knows this story in comedy Eddie Griffin
you know Eddie Griffin schreiter
anywhere knows the best writer in common
I don't know he has a writer oh did he
get a writer oh he's had it forever
right no right or mean like the thing he
pronounces [ __ ] wrong
writer go manatees great so but
apparently his rider which means like
the [ __ ] that's in the green room yeah
any means a brand new pair of Air Force
Ones for every show a lot of people do
that what yeah yeah a lot of people have
like sneaker riders wait a minute yeah
it [ __ ] up cuz I haven't asked for
anything but water you would think
sneaker the most important thing in
stand-up right there are more than just
80s yeah some guys have it where they
want a fresh pair size 11s whatever they
were right there so they get to the
plate the number want to wear them at
all until right when they get on stage
that's it yeah what's in your Ryder
I was like Jack Daniels wine meat um
water simple sugar-free Red Bull what
kind of meat you're not specific with
the meat know like like meat plates like
roast beef and [ __ ] like that so I don't
eat garbage right now nothing nuts
macadamia nuts and pistachios normal
[ __ ] red M&Ms the only really saying
about stand-up is the beauty of
Independence though right yeah that's
why that's why everybody who gives me to
run to the stand of things afterwards
cuz the comedy club still accepted sorry
they were saying did you see that tweet
I thought maybe was I would or something
like that he was like oh Jay will be
doing stand-up in three months dude do
you watch those videos no why do you why
do we love it I love it I'll tell you
loot or the world there's a lot of BS
out there he does videos on Twitter take
that [ __ ] they instigate doesn't know he
thinks Twitter is bad Thanks he's
holding his reading glasses in his hand
I mean he's going blind he's 71 years
old you just see the the the DME sent
that dude amazing with all the movies
but you understand that what strategic
right he sent that on monday monday was
the 25th anniversary of the [ __ ]
Bronco chase so you think that he didn't
just want to be in the news like that
was all I was I was a strategic move I
don't think he's
smart I think what's going on it's he
reacting to someone [ __ ] with him and
he doesn't he doesn't know how to just
let [ __ ] slide so somebody makes a
parody video where he's doing his
Twitter hello Twitter world and then
someone's got how police in the
background and who DMS that person who
made that video I'm gonna cut you I
don't think he said I'm gonna cut yeah
yeah yeah I just now a strategic man I
think he knew it was the 25th
anniversary of the Bronco chase and OJ's
only relevant is the fact that he got
away with murder so he has to remind us
of that fact all the time in order for
us to give a [ __ ] did you ever see the
videos he did when he was doing rap when
he was dressing up like King in Miami
yeah he dressed like a rapper yeah no no
yet Jamie yeah we can't we can't play
around off of youtube real quick that
stuff was fake that Dan was a mister
they actually like broke it down
instantly he made in a fake account with
like it was the real OJ he just made the
L a capital I
donkey today for no [ __ ] reason and
I'm back I'm glad I'm glad he's not that
stupid donkey today the segment I doing
The Breakfast Club I give somebody the
credit they deserve it being stupid I'm
like yeah you can't be that stupid that
thirsty for attention Oh Jay so it's
kind of it's kind of a relief that he's
not that thirsty
this is Oh Jay when he was doing rap
music right no no we can't and now he is
yeah we can't play the music but he had
girls out there dancing around their
underwear and the Oh Jay was rapping
didn't you have like a crown on or
something there is dressed up in like
white face and all sorts of things
there's naked girls in it oh god you
don't think oh they been riding a wave
of killing these two people for too long
well crazy [ __ ] will still [ __ ] him
bro he's insane I don't understand this
this at this part of women at all like
the women that like meet people in jail
and then they like get married to them
and oh yeah
look what is this about it's about the
jail dick when they come home some of
those guys never get to give him that
jail dick they're in jail forever and
then get no conjugal visits and they
still want to marry him but they're why
are attracted to killers so they want
killers they want killers and
specifically they want killers that kill
women what yeah that's a thing with some
women with really [ __ ] up women they
they're attracted to men who kill women
okay happen the girls want to get choked
[Applause]
do you think do you think all the
choking and like you know how like some
girls have a great fantasies do you
think that's all because men have just
become such [ __ ] they want to see if
they have the ability to even do it no I
think some girls have this primal need
to know that you can kill them no this
turns them on right protect them is that
Caleb yeah for sure but they want to
know you could kill them not that you're
going to kill them or catch someone else
trying to get them that's that hand on
your neck yeah Tokyu they want to be
like close to the door of you doing
something vile to them while you're
[ __ ] them so it feels good why you
got control over their life you really
have like you're holding their net you
control right no so why do we
you know these dudes that like jerk off
with like a belt on their neck and check
that we call them weirdos it's just
women yeah but that's different this
that's auto-erotic asphyxiation it is
but I think the choking is you're doing
it man is doing it to you it's not just
that you're running out of oxygen
because someone's squeezing the blood
out of your brain right but it's also
that someone's doing it to you while
your mother-fucking do you guys go for
the whole choke cuz what I do is I like
put my hand there and then I kind of
just tense my forearm but I don't really
squeeze the fingers cuz I want you know
cuz like that she won't let me do that
she wants the whole choke no she doesn't
like that oh she doesn't like that yeah
she knows you could do it well it's not
just that it's like she sees you choke
people out regularly she knows you're
capable but the kind of girl that wants
you to choke her like that I think you
should leave that one alone dude my wife
like the lucho give me we've got no did
all of that stuff was kind of like
subsided but she's like a lot of choking
you know even together 22 years yeah you
want to play but I think it's really
because they see men as pathetic now
they see men as babies and the more
pathetic and like cooked up a guy is
they're like okay choke me slapped me
around show me that you have some
testosterone show me you have some sort
of strain gotta go give ol Jason [ __ ]
oh my god you choked him Richard Ramirez
to have girls visiting him Manson that
was married when he died Manson had
charm he must've had something no he
must have had fame fame has always been
in a trap was he famous in the beginning
when he was getting people to do all
that wild [ __ ] he was man bit Manson
right well he wasn't famous but he was a
cult leader so right so he was the
leader of a small group so he was
infamous infamous amongst that group of
people yeah you gotta at least turn a
couple people to turn it into a cult
like eventually it becomes part of it
but if you look at social media you
realize that any really [ __ ] right it
ain't really [ __ ] to have a following
you know I'm saying 500 followers on
social media is pathetic right but 500
in real life yo huge him you're the man
Jim Jones especially in 67 yeah
you get 10 people - you get 10 people to
kill yourself 67 oh man some people
can't get 10 people - a comedy that's
what I'm saying you would have met and
no like you got a fax um like there's no
organization everything has to happen in
real life
yeah what would I want beach like death
no he must have the speech when he made
everybody drink the kool-aid bro let me
tell you something that's involved he
had that must have been they know they
were drinking that it wasn't even
kool-aid you know cool they took a bad
rap it was some like cheap Costco brand
with kool-aid existed even back then I
think who late existed so they went with
the generic dude it's like they didn't
have enough money for all cool they
should try to get at Big Papi no resorts
that said that was an assassination
attempt well the people are dying at
these resorts their lists and all these
Americans that are being poisoned one
lady got beaten to death and raped she
didn't get beaten to death but like
beaten half to that she survived but
like her whole head was just big swollen
mass of blood and injuries yeah
everything worked at the worked at this
resort she saw him wearing at least he
was wearing an outfit clubbed her over
the head and did all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
her and left her for dead did I read a
story today as a group of high school
kids and went to the dr of celebrating
graduation or whatever all of them ended
up in the hospital and nobody knows why
this is happening nine people have died
at these resorts that nobody knows what
a lot of them are dying from pulmonary
edema and heart failure that it's like
some blood issue and they're drinking
things from the minibar and minibar okay
yes what what is the number of people
died over there now seven nine nine nine
nine it's happening in the resorts the
safe spots
yeah it's happening in the real [ __ ]
yeah
the odd awful we got to go to dr what do
what we don't know what that's hunting
right there wait let's get into it this
is a this is let's get to the bottom of
it
want to do some nature [ __ ] Joe you
wanna go do some matrix it let's go hunt
some rapists in the dr I wonder what's
happening I don't think it's right as
people die from drinking if they said
drinking at these mini bars and drinking
at these bars and like they've been
testing the alcohol and it's like fake
alcohol or some [ __ ] like that I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on
I just know nine people have died yeah
I'm not going no yeah I'm not going yeah
you can't take this all it takes you
know it takes us nine people going to
[ __ ] up your whole tourist economy you
would think yeah but we live in this
arrow people like oh [ __ ] let's go over
there and see if we can survive the dr
like it's become like a [ __ ] game um
yeah well yeah well this one anybody
dies of a cocaine overdose everybody
wants a [ __ ] oh right wait you want the
good [ __ ] yeah what the should they do
coke no never ever done it you ever do
coke a fakes enough cold ones I smoked
it in a blunt with some wheat okay I can
the day but I fakes nifty like thanks it
was like the lines were on the table and
I just wanted to make you people out of
the round feel comfortable almost like
on some training days you think I going
to cover copper [ __ ] you just
do like this black just say what they're
doing coast to Ric Flair whoo I've had T
that mata de cocoa tea what is that he
made out of coca leaves yeah any of
those yeah apparently the leaves if you
just chew more actually good for you
they're phytonutrients it's like copper
it's like a cup of coffee okay like but
it's healthy it's actually good for you
like those high those high altitude
herders they put a big wad of that [ __ ]
in their mouth they chew on it and then
it releases into their bloodstream and
it's actually healthy it's not bad for
you it's when they process it and turn
it into cocaine that it's bad that's
when it gets what I've had is coca
leaves in a tea form so you just take
the leaves and it's like in a tea bag
and you drink the tea it just makes you
kind of like hyper and you talk too much
I'm not allowing I've smoked that
cocaine with that weed by accident that
was the best high I've ever had in my
mother [ __ ] really yes I used to always
say I would do it again by accident if
it was
by accent hoppers I think I'm too old
for that [ __ ] now but back then my god I
remember that high like it was yeah why
what a feeling like he said if you just
feel like very alive like you feel aware
like everything just seems bright even
when it's dark out and it's just like
you feel like you're actually on top of
something right it's just like you just
feel mad hyper but when you crash you
cry over when you crash try Holly yeah
MDMA I'm doing a yeah yeah yeah same
sure it was nice though you like it or
no I love the feeling when I was on it I
did not like the next day I couldn't
read I was trying to read a magazine and
I couldn't read it I just can't I
couldn't follow it yeah my brain was so
dried out just shut down just it was
just dead and then I went on stage that
night and ate [ __ ] yeah cuz you the
synapses are fire Oh slow and sloppy my
delivery was off [ __ ] though cuz you say
they [ __ ] I thought literally I was like
oh I can't wait to hear this started
reaching in your [ __ ] pants so I've
been go to Burning Man last few years
right really yeah last three years I see
bro dude it's not even really like it
for me Lisa I haven't even really been
[ __ ] there no no dude you don't
you're not showering you're all [ __ ]
hopped up on drugs and checked in I
think like the [ __ ] communities exist
but I don't want to sell it it's it's
weird to like sell it but it's a really
cool experience you would probably
really love it but um and I tried Molly
and it was you know people say like when
you try drugs it gives you this
heightened version of reality that you
can't come to naturally right and then
you have a new perspective because of it
some people say about like acid or
mushrooms and these types of things um
it was weird be used for the first time
my life I felt past emotionally fill
full it was like excess does that make
sense
you don't you kill on stage and you walk
off and you just want to like help
people yeah cuz you filled up the void
and then you have a little extra right
yeah Somali put me there and I was like
oh this is how people who feel no void
operate like I was just calling my
parents I was calling my best friends
and tell them I love them and I'm gonna
take care of your kids if anything
happens like what
oh yeah maybe they gave you the courage
to do things you want to do but for
whatever reason you choose not to write
because you know before I'm busy trying
to fill the void mm-hmm right be it
through laughs or through content
whatever we're doing and here I had the
excess and it was an interesting
experience to make me go okay I can
probably hit this maybe without the drug
I can do things in my life exercise or
rather to gratitude 100% yeah Oh dr.
Wayne WI say that you won't try find
your true purpose your true purpose in
life is service to others right so I
think most people that are public
servants and like give their lives to
other people like I think they that's
the ultimate high but it's so crazy it's
like you don't get to notice that until
you're there like it's so easy to sell
if you tell people hey you should be
grateful and then you'll feel better but
if they're not able to feel the
sensation of gratitude you're explaining
to them you're explaining Chinese to
someone who doesn't even know what the
[ __ ] the languages yeah right like we're
all in this like unique situation where
we've probably experienced that we
probably you know it tried to find ways
to give back etc and then we felt really
good because of it more like I should
keep doing this this is a really good
feeling but imagine someone who's like
barely surviving yeah but they still
have something to give they just don't
realize it like you you might have ten
dollars in your bank account but guess
what it's a homeless person on the
street that has zero you give them a
dollar you might feel great and then we
take that dollar and he's so
appreciative like thank you thank you
like that'll make you it immediately
feel better yeah really just helping
people without any you know you have no
ulterior motive or it's a great feeling
well I thought about that with karma
right like we always look at calm and we
think that calm is what you put out is
what you're supposed to get back no
karma is just in action and you're
supposed to do those things just because
it's the right thing to do yeah period I
think also karma involves you feeling
the way you feel about yourself
because when you do shitty things you
feel you have a bad self-image you live
in your karma that's what people don't
get it's not like here's a dollar for a
homeless guy five minutes later I should
get ten dollars it's not an investment
karma right it's no I feel better when
I'm acting right like it's simple as
that I can't run from yourself like no
you go to sleep every night you look in
the mirror
like and when you jack off you know what
you think about new jack I'm like you
know you and I think a lot of people
don't understand that concept like it
won't change like I can't do people
dirty because I know I did somebody
there I can't do something because I
carry that because I know I did
something fast you know and even when
somebody does something fried of me I
rap I gotta go through my files in my
mind I do something [ __ ] up to this
person that I'd do something that caused
them the right this way
no I didn't that's their problem and
that's the competitive advantage of
sociopaths is they don't carry the
negative karma sure right they have the
interaction we the three of us would
walk around afterwards like man I should
have [ __ ] done that what the [ __ ] was
wrong with me I feel like a piece of
[ __ ] they just go yeah all right that
happened I don't believe it
no that's why they if they're effective
in business that's why they're effective
in politics that's why you see these
personality types succeed with the
ability to just destroy thousands of
lives you would just say but I think
eventually it catches up to all of them
I think it does emotion just suppressing
[ __ ] so much but eventually I think
that's just I think that she just
explodes and then it causes them to go
crazy if they don't [ __ ] get killed
there are people though that don't
experience any emotions the way we
experience no empathy yeah
there's they're broken there's something
wrong with the synapses yeah like that
for a long time yeah yeah yeah yeah I
said when I when I started going to
therapy is when I started like piecing
things together but I I made myself cold
just because of how to protect yourself
yeah and how I felt like the world and
the business was treating me yeah at a
certain point yeah me I I was purposely
making myself code and I thought that
was the way that I had to be you [ __ ]
around read books like the 48 laws of
power when you're young and you know you
study all of these people who got to a
certain point they all had like this
this justjust coldness about them like
this ruthlessness like I'll step on
anybody to get the way I need to be but
then you realize these [ __ ] are
miserable that's the same dude so you're
on the island right lanai yeah right
and were you hanging out with anybody
Island folk song yeah so there's this a
comic named little Duvall he's at Lee's
I really think he's one of the people
who understands life better than anybody
on this play my guy and it was he's a
good buddy of ours he's [ __ ] and
brilliant and he says dude for the smile
[ __ ] song there you go
joe-joe when I'm telling stander comes
out to that side no shell stick easy man
let's move on this pious last time we
were talking about how is he was gonna
do it man oh but um he's one of these
guys I promise you his understanding of
life is unparalleled
unparalleled to anybody I've ever said
and you see a song like smile [ __ ] and
we see it maybe on surface value but
everything he does has a purpose and
he's aware of the purpose right
he's aware the energy puts out the
ecosystem and how it affects the
ecosystem and he was telling me how he
likes to go to the islands I visit him
in Bahamas and he likes to be in the
moms I was like why do you like to pair
he goes because people understand what
life is here I go what he talked about
he goes they don't get caught up in a
[ __ ] that we caught it get caught up
in the states right and like in the
States everybody here thinks they're
gonna be a millionaire everybody yes
we've got a lottery a reality show some
viral video and you go to the island and
they understand that they're gonna live
and die there and then they start to
realize hey I got to just maximize
happiness in life try to get some
chicken tenders on the island when we're
Bahamas it takes fifty 50 minutes an
hour for [ __ ] five chicken tenders
I'm like why [ __ ] has it taken so long
and he looked at me he goes why should
they hurry it's real Buddhists like it's
a lot of it is a lot he doesn't he
doesn't know that but philosophy is like
he's he's aware of Buddhist you don't
even know you called my nothing who's
Buddha's he be like I ain't I didn't go
to school no Buddha but he knows
instinctively he have no formal
education comes from nothing and the way
that he's found a way to understand
humanity it says competitive advantage
in industry then he just truly
understands made fast we've complicated
this year dude we had like capitalism as
complicated things you know the cultures
that we scribed to be a part of have
complicated things the truth didn't
matter is life is about treating people
good being a public servant and dying
the crazy thing he goes he goes I love
my life and this is what's hard to
understand because I love hanging out
old people I'm like why here's because
they understand life I know what do you
mean because you you'll eventually get
to a certain point where you realize
you're gonna die and all these things
that you want to accomplish that you
thought you had to accomplish and all
this [ __ ] that you thought you had to
get done in order value yourself as is
meaningless it was just distraction
until we get there you
that's the concept by being hard to
swallow yeah because you have to let go
of ego right you have to go you have to
go ok I'm ok as I am and I'm ok having a
good conversation with somebody or good
interaction today or just [ __ ]
sitting on the beach and looking at the
Stars right these are cool things that's
just as valuable as having a YouTube
clip hit a million or something like
that these these things aren't any
different in the grand scope grand scope
of things right yeah I believe in the
law of attraction right your thoughts
become things so that's why I thought
for me to graph the concept of okay
Wendy you're gonna die because in my
mind I want to die with him ninety a
hundred years old but you know you read
certain things and he like no you have
to embrace it you have to tell yourself
every day you're gonna die because then
you'll live your life like every day is
your last yeah I
that's a hard concept you know Ct
Fletcher I've heard that name so he said
the hour looking back - yeah he had a
heart transplant last year and he came
on the podcast a year after his heart
transplant and you've never seen a guy
more loving and open and friendly and
thankful and tells everybody loves him
he's hugging everybody and just
genuinely grateful because he was at
death's door like legitimately intest
doors heart was failing him his father's
hearted failed them his brothers his
like he's got congenital heart disease
in his family and he knew that his heart
was going he had had heart attacks he'd
had surgery and they transplanted his
[ __ ] heart and a put a woman's heart
inside of him - well I also [ __ ] with
him that's what he's like Wow no but it
means just like just that's one the one
that fit yeah you know there was like
this is matches you and we're ready to
do it
BAM so now here here he is a year later
but that guy has like this renewed lease
on life and he just glows like a like a
like a religious figure as he got close
yeah it's very concept for a movie like
somebody who was a male chauvinist all
his life and [ __ ] on women and then
had to get a woman's heart
yeah hole jealous for no reason
yeah pretty crazy but it is interesting
it's like that's what now we're getting
to the [ __ ] up thing right like this
idea there is no good and bad things
just are etc right but like but there's
good and bad in how the the energy that
you put out how it affects people you do
a bad thing and it hurts a bunch of
people's lives yes
that's you're really you're changing how
those people are going to interact with
all the people they experience as well
yes and there's a ripple effect with the
ecosystem right but like let's say you
look at like you early we're talking
about like bears mm-hmm right or maybe I
was watching a clip of your show but
you're talking to and Duncan and you're
like bears really just attacked baby
animals that's what they maybe do
whatever they can but the moat they eat
most most of the baby deer the dog they
just eat they're like animal pedophiles
right they're just killing [ __ ] kids
right that's what they do coca-cola
sponsor is an animal pedophile just
eating baby seals frame so that in our
culture would be a piece of [ __ ] what if
there was a group of people that just
killed kids right right we would call
the pieces of [ __ ] that would be a bad
thing right right but that's just you've
acknowledged within the you know the
ecosystem of that of those animals it's
necessary yeah right the Bears need to
how do we know though how do we know
that is not [ __ ] groups of animal
rights activist animals in the woods we
don't know these animals are really
talking about a really disgusting no no
you know the shark's fin soup yo
Charlotte you know the shark's fin soup
no city cut they just cut the fins off
the shark and then they let the shark
sink to the bottom of the ocean and die
and die right it just sinks of the bay
can't swim it just sinks to the bottom
and there's somebody tweeting about how
horrible it is but I bet there's a bunch
of fish that are pulling up on that
shark like oh look what we got here yeah
don't just stand there when they see you
know they get the [ __ ] on right [ __ ]
humans with them guns again oh yeah like
I think animals are way smarter than we
give them credit for well they have
instincts no more than things some some
do some animals are smart you know
what's interesting moose are some of the
dumbest the dumbest [ __ ] but do
because you know why so big cuz who's
gonna take them out yeah there's so big
all they have to do is stomp stomp
wolves that's all they have to do
wolves try to come after them and then
they just came on if I wasn't moves I'd
be dumb too though cuz I'll be looking
at y'all like y'all dumb y'all really
out here with us yeah and they just
muffled oh God you don't have the nerve
to try me from Game of Thrones what that
what's that guy's name yeah thorn board
you don't know is IQ but I can't imagine
it's incredible mmm you think yeah six
nine 300 pounds y'all got a figure [ __ ]
out it might not have to but some dudes
choose to this giant dudes that are
smart as [ __ ]
small [ __ ] that's what level people
would like to think that's what I have
to think you have to to make yourself
feel better six nine always say that
about Shaq someone saying that about oh
he's got a little dick compared to who
compared to a bear
I read current stuff is book current
stuff and said she had sex relationship
ahead superhead she said it's not little
it's just regular so like his dick pile
look big on me is a really big for you
shed Chris Rock joke about the
background he's like I don't have a big
dick but I got a small background need
to come through with the time-warner
remote that should be that boring
company what did that call it Joe the
boring complain I'm not a flame thrower
yeah that's what shocked me yeah
disappoint a woman I guess what I'm
saying is like like with Ct Fletcher
right he need to see death in order to
like have this amazing revelation about
life and maybe the fucked-up things that
happen in the world right maybe if there
is some sort of design to all this maybe
the fucked-up things that happen in the
world allow us to have a little bit of
empathy and joy for being able to be
here but you got to give a [ __ ] about
life first of all because I can think
about all the near-death experiences I
had whether it was somebody pulling a
gun on me whether it was you know me
being drunk his [ __ ] and wrecking my
mom's white loom in the caravan and
literally the only reason I survived is
because I didn't have a seatbelt on
because I was so drunk that
impact didn't kill me I didn't think
about stuff like that until decades
later it happened in the moment it was
just like all right whatever I got into
a wreck oh I got a gun put on me but
when you're old in you you know I got
three daughters and I look at my wife
and I look at people that love and care
about me and I really appreciate in
value life now I start thinking about
gonna see like what the [ __ ] was I think
right I think it was [ __ ] about life
back then but I can get an anxiety
attack thinking about those past moments
because those primers would have caused
so much not to happen yeah if I did I
yeah it's got a care you got a care and
you have to have something to care for
and that's one of the things that really
changes when you have children oh
absolutely
just change your pelson have best thing
to me he said not only did it change how
much I love he was it changed my
capacity for love it teaches you how to
love yeah you might not even know what
real love is until you have children and
you realize like man just like my heart
walking around outside my body yeah and
you feel a different level of love a
different level of empathy like like I
remember my daughter had to track me
like two three years ago and she was
learning the long jump and you know he
was like the first time she ever did the
long jump so it was literally I wasn't
gonna meet with like practice right and
so she goes to do the jump and I just I
go oh my god that was horrible and she
just burst out into tears and I'm like
what the [ __ ] did I just - what did I
say my wife is like it was just what's
your problem
and then other parents are coming like
oh it'll be fine you did perfectly guys
I shut the [ __ ] up she didn't do good
but I didn't understand that my word
meant everything like everything so I
just took all her confidence out of her
and just that one snap of a finger like
Thanos and that should even thinking
about that [ __ ] now hurts my heart but
I've never made that mistake again
now I'm the father that that that overly
tells her how great she is and and I
know how to explain her if she does
something that I necessarily don't think
is great I know how to explain it to her
in a way where she can do better and
she's very receptive to this yeah change
it changes who you are you how many kids
three ok sell all daughters 200 you was
a hole in a past life let me go I'm
telling you this is Tara
I have a joke about about how much it
changed the way I feel about life is
that when my daughter was little
there was two bananas and one of them
was brown and fucked-up and old and one
of them was perfect and I looked at
those who bananas and I know my daughter
loves bananas so she probably want that
nice banana so I ate that fucked-up
banana with mashed potato textured
banana I was thinking about this and not
another person in this world I would do
that for because I love my wife my wife
is an amazing person but it was just me
and my wife I'd be like ooh I guess that
[ __ ] is getting a shitty you would jump
in front of a bus for her different
things so like this people say I would
die for you they don't mean it most of
the time unless they're a soldier who's
willing to dive on a [ __ ] grenade yes
but if I could die and I knew that my
kids would be happy and healthy uh-oh if
but if I lived they would die I would
die I flew out I flew out I flew out
here I left I left New York 5:30 this
morning simply because I was opposed to
fly out last night but my daughter had a
tract dinner which I forgot about and it
was literally like a tract dinner it's
in a [ __ ] gym and they're serving
chicken tenders and lasagna and pizza
and listening to Oldtown rolled ten
different times everybody gets to
participate participation trophies but I
stayed just to be there change my flag
right there just a flower this morning
cuz I needed to be there for that track
day yeah that's the you don't do that
for people that you don't absolutely
love in a door so here's a question you
both have these kids and you need to
balance loving them so much and telling
them the most amazing people in the
entire world
and not making them horrible human
beings well more than that not making
them weak weak you have to give them
adversity or they'll never know what to
do with I think sports is that the key
to that make them do not know it's
difficult well I know what you're saying
about participation trophies but get him
involved in something competitive where
they have to struggle so they'll learn
what it's like to lose they'll learn
what what life is like in a kind of
controlled environment and then you can
still nurture them and love yeah the
difference between people participate in
sports and people don't as you learn
what losing is and some people that
never learn what losing is and they just
are terrified of it but they're not
teaching these kids how to lose in some
in school schools but I mean like
competitive things like get your kids
involved in martial arts get your kids
involved in these things that are just
it's very clear the binary one or zero
either you win or you lose those those
are important you learn you learn like
what struggle is if you have a race
right track meets a perfect example
someone [ __ ] won yeah someone did not
win that's it you know like who you got
across the line and I'm second [ __ ] yeah
I gotta be first house what can I be
first I gotta figure out a run fast run
fast that's it
well you guys ever will you guys ever be
openly disappointed in them will you
show them that they let you down the
only time I'm that way with my kids when
they're mean to each other I tell them I
go this is unnecessary I know why why
you're feeling this way I know why
you're mad at each other but you can't
be shitty to your sister you can't do
that it's a bad thing you got to learn
how to take a deep breath and think
about the consequence of what you're
saying and every time you do do
something shitty learn from it yeah you
know it's like it's a learning
experience I think for me I'm just like
that when I when I think that they're
being ungrateful but my daughter my
oldest daughter ten my second oldest is
three but so she doesn't really
understand the concept other daughters
nine one so but my tenure is have lived
a very privileged life and sometimes you
see that bougie [ __ ] come out
listen little things like like I love
this island called Anguilla I not I mean
and we vacation like two three times a
year like these long 10-day vacations
just like a koala chain using Grenada
and hurry my knees my knees comes with
me all the time and it is talking like
the food is so much better if in a
single-wide [ __ ] trailer like that is
the only thing that like pisses me off
this lack of gratitude but that's
perspective issue though right never
there they're wealthy they're never
gonna understand what it's like to do so
how do you instill that in us impossible
you know it's not anyways I'm a mess man
all of my favorite people have [ __ ] up
child yes but I don't want my kids ever
my mom told me we're here to make our
children's lives better like my mom
actually showed me like my
great-great-grandfather's
taxes he had to pay one year and I was
like a quarter like it was something
light but back then that was a lot of
money so she was just saying that to me
ever to tell me that every generation is
supposed to be better cuz I got this
thing sometimes well I feel guilty about
doing so well because I don't have no
[ __ ] skillset like I didn't go to
college you know what I'm saying like
I'm not I don't feel special like why am
i in the position that I'm in my mother
was a school teacher with 30-plus years
most she ever made was $30,000 in cycle
Anna I get that for a [ __ ] appearance
so it's like that [ __ ] will make you
feel bad sometimes like you'll feel a
sense of guilt so she was just showing
me that to say hey every generation is
supposed to be better than the next
generation so our kids are supposed to
be way better than us
yeah but don't you want to prepare them
for that life like you look at any one
of these movies or even stories about a
a king that took power and then the son
that he has son he has always some
spoiled little [ __ ] who ruins the
kingdom
well that's the thing find me a great
man is the son of a great man find me a
man find me a great man who's the son of
a great man
because a great man always has these
weak little sons and it's like how do
you it like maybe you do need to create
adversity for your kid maybe
do need to be a dick a little bit and
maybe it's selfish to be sweet to your
kid all the time because you're not
preparing them for the world when you're
not there I think you prepared him for
the world when you let them find their
own way
yes meaning like you got to cut a cord
yeah I don't want my I don't want my
daughter to get in the media you know if
they choose to cool you know my daughter
likes to write now so she wants to be an
author fine I'm not I'm not really an
author who wrote a couple books you know
I'm saying write what it goes right then
that gives them that integrity and that
purpose and everything else that they're
looking for yeah I think when you hand
him things yeah that's when the Eagle
yes they have to work for what I see in
the communities that I live in is I
always like the rich kids that have
nannies that take them everywhere and
they don't see their parents very much
because their parents work all the time
and their parents vacation without the
kids they like to go places without the
kids all the time there's you see a lot
of that those kids are getting [ __ ] up
and you see them as they get older
they're more and more vacant more and
more weird more and more detached yes
you know but the kids that around the
family all the time they do things with
the family then they get a richer
experience it's it's neglect and it's
the parents that are like super driven
and they're never home they're working
16 hours a day and that's why they live
in this [ __ ] giant mansion and drive
around in the Bentley like though those
kids get [ __ ] up and they wound up
getting on drugs and empty and looking
for something to fill them up imagine
your parents sent you to boarding school
I have a buddy mine - Bryan Callen his
parents sent her to [ __ ] boarding
school in the United States and they
didn't even live in the United States
they sent him to another country Jesus
where where's Bryan from I love Bryan
Bryan is from all over the world his dad
was a banker an international banker air
quotes mm-hmm and traveled everywhere
and was involved in some weird gun
boring [ __ ] weapon deals we could talk
later but he was involved in UFOs and
weapon the weird [ __ ] and then sent his
kit was [ __ ] 13 years old sent him to
the United States go to boarding school
and Bryan's his day still little show
because of it yeah dude imagine your
parents send you away feel like we're 13
it's yours I can often imagine if you
was at boarding school and got [ __ ]
molested or something you would really
hate like saying something funny that
hasn't been yeah you got to get that
funny diddle then something [ __ ] up
happened really yeah if you're [ __ ] up
if you're funny something [ __ ] up
anything yes yeah yeah I mean sometimes
some pain some strong note you have to
learn it you have to learn it why would
you need funny it's like it's but that's
why it's so rare to see and people
always say this about women but like
even attractive dudes like have you ever
seen like a male model that was funny
right let's say about girls carrot top
unless you're fat your stories suck real
talk
it's true dude unless you have to earn
[ __ ] like lesbians are hilarious yes
tragic is [ __ ]
yeah sorry yes stank she's not fat no
meshes no no but she had a tragedy the
tragedy is y'all say it being a fan of
the tragedy yes [ __ ] that's why miss
Patterson larious because you never want
your kid to become Miss Pat but you love
miss patty yeah you love me spent only
because like that when you go through
that kind of trauma when you come out on
the other side you're really unstoppable
yeah especially when you deal with
what's going on in here
which is the toughest part right now I
think that's what comedy does comedy is
therapy for a lot of people there before
a lot of people it gives you an escape
well that's why she was able to accept
what that guy did to her and forgive him
because she just she's past it
yeah she's on the other side yeah she's
gotten through on the other side and it
forces you to deal with the reality of
the world like I think comics better
than most people deal with the reality
of the world and often it's because
we've went through some kind of real
[ __ ] right so we go oh yeah these things
happen so I can let my mind even operate
in it when you exist in like a really
privileged life emotionally and even
mentally when you exist in that space
you don't
want to imagine that there are people
starving you don't want to imagine their
people hungry or that their parents are
abused their kids you don't even want to
go there because you don't have to when
you grew up in it like yeah that's what
the life is where's the fun right
my dad can hit me for it for [ __ ] my mom
when you travel you can appreciate where
you're going where's your daughter's
like again I went to South Africa in
December it was like the hundredth year
of Mandela could have been his hundredth
birthday or something like that and so I
took my daughter my ten-year-old
daughter so like a few months later she
had a project in school where she had to
do a project about Nelson Mandela in
South Africa and so she had printed this
picture of the Nelson Mandela statue in
from Mandela Square and had it as the
cover and I'm like where's the picture
of you next to the statue and she's like
I don't want to use that you don't want
to use the picture of you standing next
to the actual statue in Nelson Mandela
Square that's the point of these
experiences because you're able to do
things like that I had to explain that
to her yet the teacher had a flex to her
yeah and she was like I don't even need
to use this as a cover for my book oh I
think she's embarrassed you don't think
she didn't want the other kids to do
well like yeah yo would you guys you
guys got you got some money and you got
kids would you guys pay to get your kid
into a good school
oh like that lady didn't know no [ __ ]
chance
absolutely I'm gonna earn that [ __ ] yeah
you gotta earn that [ __ ] you can't do
that because they're not gonna enjoy it
and they're not gonna direct gonna work
hard yeah those some of those people
paid a half a million dollars right so
good only in Bachelor to get a shitty
shitty kid yeah into some school that
they didn't deserve yeah and the kids
not gonna have no passion for what they
know when you know I'm saying that just
they're like they gotta [ __ ] is just
like having a regular piece of paper
like I want I want my kids to do things
that they really want to do that's how
you change the world you change the
world when you're doing things that you
that you're wanted
but what's funny I thought is that those
kids that went to the school like did
fine at them
so yes the school is just a big [ __ ]
hustle it's like if they didn't earn it
based on grades they should fail right
the [ __ ] out of the school it's becoming
a hustle just because of the way the
world is working yeah Jamie went to
school for audio engineering he's not a
goddamn thing he learned in school he
could use today
really yeah I mean for the most part I
got to touch some stuff I could never
have touch before but I mean it was like
2005 maybe YouTube didn't exist and
there wasn't the plethora of knowledge
out there that 12 year olds are teaching
you how to record audio right whereas I
had to learn from the guy that was
recording Eminem and jay-z you know
these guys dr. Dre right like they can't
really do much with that job either
besides teach it now either so that's
why I'd like to go back to Joel's point
when you said I'm gonna last and radio
the reason I'm probably the last and
radio is because I'm the guy that's
tearing people away from real when kids
come on community but y'all wanna get in
the radio I'm like fool what type of
different ways to be heard you can go on
YouTube and if you want to be a VJ on TV
you can start doing your own video
countdowns on YouTube like why do you
need TV or radio that's your middle man
gone yeah I had to be on a radio radio
you had to be on TV we didn't have that
[ __ ] growing up you know I'm even
experiencing that with commentary for
the UFC because I love doing commentary
for the UFC but you know what I love you
better I do these fight companions yes
when you want you get in here with your
hand when you start smoking weed and
talking [ __ ] and we watch the fights on
the screen we have the best time it's
way more fun than being there live do
you think that's the future of all live
events right so you could watch the NBA
Finals and instead of listening to the
guys you know Marv Albert or whoever do
it you could choose your guys that you
watch the commentary with Oh fight
companion for basketball football you
know I was doing that with Snoop Dogg he
had he had the Tuesday night contender
series Anoop dog and Urijah Faber we're
doing commentary and snoop would just
have a constant blunt lit and he was
drinking Tanqueray and getting hammered
hi and talking crazy [ __ ] that was an
option
for the commentary you should be options
noop cast it should write it should be
every single one sleep got tired of
doing it though stop doing it he'll
Snoopy I thought I'd get around Dana
White ah I think he just got tired of
you know having to be there every
Tuesday well that's the beautiful things
we show the NBA did this during the
finals this year they tried an
alternative stream using the ESPN app
right so the thing about this is you're
doing it with the ESPN guys yeah correct
right so it's like what would be great
is do it with like the funniest
commentary guys that you like in your
life right here them just the reason why
people tune into your thing I guarantee
they probably mute the TV right the
people who are watching they listen to
both I think that's what people probably
do so you never let the good commentator
is commentating anything that I'm saying
Berkeley Kimmy's Memphis Shaq should be
actually commentating during the NBA and
it would be incredible during the game
it would be incredible yeah I'm talking
[ __ ] to each other matter of fact put
them on a little screen in the bottom so
we can actually look at them visually
what they're doing I don't know I just
think do that with the UFC they have the
best guys doing like Daniel Cormier does
it's great
Dominick Cruz Paul Felder you know they
have good fighters Michael Bisping that
do commentator now
Cormier is the best oh yeah he's great
he's hilarious yeah Ben used to fight
[ __ ] cage the heavyweight champion he's
a light heavyweight champion and then he
vacated this title and no he's the
heavyweight champion yeah he does
commentator we do it all the time
together yeah you guys are right
together because you guys get [ __ ] but
we're also good friends okay so we're
always talking [ __ ] and we're laughing
about things whether it's a judge was a
nice lady but a terrible judge yeah but
this like when when Rose namajunas won
the title you start screaming out the
ground it's not like you guys turn into
fans yeah well we are I mean neither one
of us are real professionals right but
we do it for 11 and it's weird that's my
worst nightmare like to be out some way
and [ __ ] get into a argument with an
MMA fighter so when you got folded up
when keeping it real goes wrong in the
hole
other sides of it in ears here's a good
one but but the thing is you can wear
our ear cards I don't have any
cauliflower here I have a little bit on
this year but I wear ear guards it
changes the way you hear things what you
don't want that Calvo ear ossification
eye ears stick out already too much oh
they would stick out do not look at a
bat yeah you'd have a big old knots in
your yeah I can't so there's no other
signs of what a guy could be an MMA no
not real what about hands what about
knuckles no I mean you could tell not
tell you know it's no you don't know see
that's why it's got to be nice to people
[ __ ] Andy Ruiz the new way you look
at his body you would think no [ __ ]
away and you look at Anthony Joshua
sculpted out of marble Ben thought he
was trash bro yeah not that guy never he
never had in him he is literally Ivan
Drago
literally he's the UK Ivan Drago he
looks the part
ladies love him he never had that skill
in the ring I told no Breakfast Club I
don't think that's true he got dropped
by Klitschko and he came back to knock
me let's go it was an old-ass man dude
and he's Ukraine he's got Chernobyl in a
man show
yeah that's nuclear poisoning a [ __ ] he
was very old he was trying to win an
election for like this you know crazy
[ __ ] she's got a lot of things going on
his life
the real fight Anthony on t Wilder Tyson
Fury 2 closest thing we've we've had in
the heavyweight division Tolly I said
after that I said a couple of fight so I
think he is the head movement the foot
movement at his size and weight I'll
leave is doing that 212 pounds his head
was last fight was very ugly like on
amazing on violent aside guys but Ali
did that with George Foreman you see
there's a difference the guy that he was
fighting like that guy did it with
Deonte in Deonte he did it but he also
got dropped and almost murdered he died
every time I look at 12th round when
Deonte connected and then walked back
game over and the fact that he just rose
up and then outboxed him for the rest of
the round but although she has a therapy
that's although she has a therapy and
meditation hit him and knocked him out
he was in that place is still this fall
that was ko is a weird man it's like
sometimes the a punch does not look like
much and it drops you and puts you away
and sometimes you get [ __ ] flatline
like and it looks like you're over what
I mean I was amazed that the ref even
gave him a cat thought it was gonna call
him out yeah I thought I thought the ref
was gonna wave their hands yeah
meanwhile this [ __ ] rises up and
doesn't even look wobbly unbelievable by
the way Anthony Joshua can't beat Tyson
Fury he can't beat the ante watch you
can't beat Luis Ortiz well well I don't
Luis is all - here's a good 90 years old
yeah the word is and I get this from a
reliable sources inside the fight
community you know that Anthony Joshua
got dropped in training camp he's right
before the fight bad yeah my god in
Philly right I don't know yeah but bad
yeah the point where he was ko'd
essentially and that's why his dad went
after the promoter after the fight was
you see his dad screaming at the
promoter ring apparently he was just not
he's not prepared to fight and yet he
was looking bad in the locker room know
worried about a panic attack yeah I
thought he had a panic attack before the
fight and if you remember you know it
took him a while to come to the ring
like they even played and I was told
that when if you noticed when he was
walking out they was rubbing his back
and he was rubbing his head I heard he
had a panic attack well if you've been
ko like within a week you it takes
months to get your [ __ ] back together
again the whole world is like shaky -
you equilibriums off so he was in there
and then when he dropped him he's like
Jesus Christ here I go again time
no but you know when he talks to a drop
yet he's like good we got let's get this
[ __ ] out of here and then he
went right at him and then boom he got
clipped and then it was over
there's a there was a the biggest what
is the biggest upset heavyweight history
is theis Douglas versatile Yeah right
guess who got dropped in training camp
Tyson did did he
Yeah right I forget the guys name but
his sparring partner I'm in training
campus video of a huge kom he took a
knee but still it's like robbed
dropped your body shut down for a second
and it takes time to recover for that
shame at the meeting the night before he
was [ __ ] a bunch of Japanese women
would Bobby Brown in a hotel room and
doing drugs by the fire Bobby said Mike
told him I'd be right back
hey Bobby was like no you gotta fight
tonight he's like yeah yeah I'll be
right back I'm gonna knock this guy not
be right back
he still got up and he still dropped
Buster Douglas that's even crazier nah
did you ever watched it 34 30 know about
Buster Douglas no taste they had to 3430
and me I didn't realize how much he
dominated Mike Tyson oh yeah it would
like round full round yes
punishing Mike Tyson yeah I remember
that when I was just at Douglas is like
one of the most talented guys yet just
didn't have the kind of drive and
discipline that you needed to be a
champion but when his mom died mother
dad his mom it was mom man that's what
gave him all the drugs and he was
hooking off the jab on Tyson yeah Wow
yeah like in a beautiful way yes his
skill was incredible I wasn't afraid it
was a world beater yeah he was a world
beater yeah fun no motivation no no no
we feel [ __ ] him up after that he's
basically done no he was done yeah but
now he's infamous
in SMS beating Tyson when it would have
meant something to beat Mike I found out
about it after the fact I didn't watch
the fight live I had a gig that night
when I thought in real-time and then I
watched it later and I still was waiting
for Tyson to get up and beat him I
didn't believe you didn't believe it I
remember I remember watching that fight
in in my mind I guess I wasn't really
paying attention I was just like this is
longer than most Tyson fight you can
have a dinner reservation on a Tyson
back yeah I'm like it then when you
finally got [ __ ] Mike just lost not only
do we grow watching Mike [ __ ] people up
we grew up trying to beat him on Mike
Tyson punch ass say that [ __ ] was
impossible yeah so is this like dad I
was an unbelievable moment I didn't feel
like that we were even Joshua
well there's certain times with people
lose you can't believe they're lost like
for me it was Roy Jones when Tarver
knocks him out dude I was just like what
one [ __ ] boy Jones they stopped to
this day man unreal if you watch in the
second round it's a really interesting
thing that happens they both they both
throw ho
and Tarver just gets there yeah and well
Tarver is actually a South Pole right so
I think it's his is kind of like a
looping lesson but they exchange and
Tarver just his first Roy timed it and
this what happens I think when fighters
get a little bit older they lose a
fraction of a second and that fraction
of a second earlier in Roy's career he's
checking them and then he's moving out
of the way well I think the real
watch.watch Alex do you see it yeah look
at some exchange ready it's and yeah
boom at one point changes everything
everything well you know what thar was
coach said that Tarver beat him in
basketball
yes and then when he saw that he beat
him better who was his coach McGirt
buddy yeah yeah I think final that's
true dude we had we had Roy on on on
floor two and I asked him I was like we
ever worried about like getting knocked
out and like you know losing something
leaving something in the ring and he
takes a second he goes I'll be honest
with you man I didn't come and ring with
much sense to begin with so I wasn't
really worried about losing it
competitive nature to Roy
last year last year Roy was hitting me
because he really wanted to fight I
really want to fight him Rose like I got
the sponsors that can put some money I
think was like thirty million dollars I
made the call for and Michael was like
nah it is like now we good or net like
Roy would [ __ ] Michael B Jordan uh don't
let Creed fool you don't let [ __ ]
kill Magan black you still run up on one
of them old boxes right now muscle
memory will get you nothing why does
someone even be close so that's horrific
and these know what happens it's like
some guys start they surf bite fighting
or they start to an MMA they start doing
a little Brazilian Jiu Jitsu or
something like that right yeah and they
put a couple chokes in in like a safe
controlled environment and you get that
like delusional yeah confidence and
that's why sparring so important do you
remember the first time you guys sparred
sure I'm not the first time number two
laughs well you doing since you're a kid
right now okay I mean the first time I
sparred before I went in the ring I was
like uh I got this it's just combos
whatever I'm was [ __ ] for
dude frightening when the punch were
coming back yeah I'm just a shell I just
stopped yeah miss bought since the last
time I spot a spot with Shawn Porter
really yeah yeah this was nothing he was
actually throwing punches yeah cuz I was
mad but this you don't mean knock your
ass out bro and this is one of them this
guy's head movers is impeccable
I mean people try to attack him on the
street and then every single time Joe
Joe Joe it's on [ __ ] really it is
look at him
going forward this is the PR move that's
not a PR move you sweatin hmm that's it
is in Brooklyn you gotta be focused cuz
there's people yelling in there yo
shoulder me gotta make up can I get a
drop from the audience and it know I'm
right-handed I'll just trying to throw
him off a little bit really yeah you did
it on purpose did you know feet movement
do you train in boxing are we just doing
this for a goof no I just wanted the
going in I was like [ __ ] it this shot
water I'm a boxing fan I'm like you know
what the worst can happen you get
knocked the fun where's can have it as
this mean yeah you're right that could
be terrible he's become significant left
footed yeah he's not we not even really
and we went three rounds Wow now is
about to die at the end it'll three
rounds he's bold a few times I stand my
[ __ ] late I mean I hit the punching
bag Callens bars all the time and
doesn't probably one yeah Brian no no
Brian Kenner Oh DJ Khaled
one person is not doing any cardio it's
DJ calories after a Ruiz one Khaled
getting out of a car with all the big
guys the day after the title Khaled
Khaled Khaled been working out on
snapchat for a whole union didn't lose a
[ __ ] pound nice guy and got a
Weight Watchers deal god bless Amer
Weight Watchers I mean we are just a
white plate there's plus-size models
right there doing that now like Nike and
their Nike store has like a big
mannequin like a fat mannequin but they
do they don't have plus-size models for
men Joe
there is nothing that enrages me more
than fat models there is nothing that
enrages me more than fat [ __ ] ok ok let
me just say something as a comic we want
attention we don't feel like we deserve
it
so we make you laugh so there's an even
exchange I get my attention you get some
joy okay an actor they want attention
they're not willing to write the script
but they'll memorize some line so do a
little bit of effort to get the
attention a regular model at least she's
willing to lose weight so that she can
be looked at but these fat [ __ ] are
just like look at me look at using the
word in 2019 what the [ __ ] that's that's
that's the plus-size model mannequin
great you guys the only thing I don't
like and rate you that they're like just
stare at me I'm gonna eat bread all day
no but you should stare at me the only
thing that bothers me about that is
that's out of context because that's the
oversized mannequin in workout clothes
right he's going to lose the weight yeah
she's trying to lose matter so okay so I
needed some context if this is workout
gear like overweight women who want to
go lose weight cool right other than
that why are you wearing workout gear
cuz she's trying to lose weight that's
the only reason you'd be wearing that
she would she'd be even bigger if she
didn't work out she like Hallett imagine
calleb didn't DJ khaled needs to eat a
salad
[Laughter]
you gotta have a DJ Khaled level of
annoyance to succeed in life dog to you
yes you do so much but it's so much
she's in your [ __ ] shirt there's no
way you didn't know you could button
your shirt he's the epitome of not being
afraid to ask for things but it looks
like french toast Jesus every time I
look at him it's french toast and he has
no is the butter and the maple syrup
says he lost 15 kilograms
what is that 34 pounds yeah no there you
go lost 34 pounds
okay listen congratulate he can see his
dick now congratulations there's a
little slimmer on the right he does look
a little slimmer okay maybe it's a
little whoa what's Christ I don't even
know what that is
are you watching I respect a cow who
came from Radio Cali came from Radio
Khaled used to do 12 midnight to 2:00
a.m. on weekends at W edr in Miami if
I'm not mistaken needs to be Friday and
Saturday night and then I was like 15
years ago
great so radio is a lot like comedy in a
way right and that like there's like a
sort of a fellowship of radio people you
respect people who did it yeah it's so
it's so few and far between that
actually I guess make it so to speak
that you know who those players are
right I'm saying
so yeah in a way yeah and there's so few
like national ones like who's like
nationally known radio guys Elvis Duran
there's maybe a dozen um you Elvis Bobby
Tom Joyner Tom's retiring this year what
about Steve Steve national TV no CIBC
those and I respect Steve and I respect
Ryan Seacrest not really count those
guys they didn't start in radio million
grassroots didn't start in radio was the
awesome radio guy they I have no that
was a radio guy law I did his radio show
in the nineties okay so you might didn't
even know you might have a do he does
great guys five jobs right grab from
American Idol right because radio day
does it in the more any does that
secretary
radio what is that like hey Delores
you're the one who won you know like
that kind of [ __ ] by the way Ryan is
never off ya know like we work for the
same company were fired I've seen Ryan
walk out the bathroom like he's walking
on stage to introduce the next guest on
American Idol like he's always on know
that was a perfect example where like
you're gay rumors trumped you're me to
rumors what happened remember when he
caught the me too and like a girl said
that he me to it or whatever and girly
worked with something like that and then
everybody was like the gay guy he's he's
not okay what is he what is he what do
you call it all right Ryan is one of
those people you have some he is a
handsome those [ __ ] teeth but you
don't think about sex with him so what
is he right with the letters would a
sexually so sexual oh it's awesome
oh he's like oh you don't [ __ ] dude or
chicks okay I see what it is
he's always can you imagine him choking
a girl no no absolutely not I can
imagine she's beating him to death when
you hear something about him like no
nothing like he has that kind of
personality which is actually worked in
a lot of people's favor
yeah what's great for top-40 radio yeah
it's great for secretaries that call in
yes you're the seventh caller
congratulations
would you think about the finals of Game
of Thrones did it disappoint you
[Applause]
[ __ ] arrived in the UH that frequency he
is so good at being like authentic in
the most in authentic situations explain
like like hosting the show is why like
American Got Talent all that kind of
stuff you got to be like really excited
about somebody like that's really
inauthentic but he kind of comes across
as believable like sincere yeah she does
it matter
meaning like this his reactions in those
moments matter that's a pretty man
listen he's America's host he is yes
America's holes man he's a host some
dead in that song that's for sure but
say what put him on
gecoo Clark does he do the new year's
countdown now to a lot of jobs man
listen they was probably it was probably
dicks corpse corpse up for like 10 years
before they finally said Ryan just do it
yourself i when he had a stroke and he
would still do it not think dick been
dead bro wait he had a stroke he was
doing out the side of his mouth like to
face he was struggling he was definitely
struggling to talk yes it was so bad
yeah like they went from he would do it
but then it was just like they would pop
in on him in like some studio and he'd
be like sitting there struggling they're
talking like why do they keep will and
Dick Clark out with New Year's Eve like
you're actually depressing people before
the ball drops yeah and then they had
Kathy Griffin and Anderson Cooper that
was a great combination no dude she and
rages man just like the fat model no I
like Kathy cuz Kathy don't give a [ __ ]
I like Kathy were the same reason I like
I used to like John Roos I mean I say
youth because she's dead but I my own
legend but they don't they both didn't
give a [ __ ] they were cut from the same
cloth
mmm I don't know if they're cut from the
same cloth I think so man I think so I
have to love Anderson and Kathy Griffin
together I never heard anybody say that
look at that chemistry
oh yeah we got Cathy on breakfast club
now said she cut Trump's head she cut
Trump's [ __ ] head oh that was that
was a strange thing that was what was
strange about it is the fact that she
didn't think she was gonna suffer any
consequences from that I think people
forget that Donald Trump even though he
is the ex executive producer of
Celebrity Apprentice and he was a
reality star he's the President of the
United States of America its rules about
threatening heads of state yeah yeah you
just can't do things like that like what
it's hard it's almost like a [ __ ]
Flavor Flav became president it would be
hard for you to look at him as anything
other than Flavor Flav yeah but you
better respect his position
those goddamn minutes come knock on you
[ __ ] door if flavor becomes president
well Donald's the first guy who was
famous like other than Ronald Reagan I
guess Ronald Reagan was famous as an
actor apparently yeah be famous famous I
don't know how that he was famous famous
you know he was in big movies and I knew
he was the Governor of California
you know there's it's a weird one right
I mean just having a famous person in a
popularity contest is strange
yes has you got a built-in advantage yes
all of them it is a popularity contract
all of them gonna be moving for well
someone could some people might say
Obama was the first celebrity president
he became a celebrity though oh you
don't think he was one before going in -
no I have to Lulu I think there is now
not Trump is on a different level
yeah right now those commercials bro he
says come fat rap songs named after him
name is on buildings all across the
world yeah aunt giant Trump letters he
was a bread truck yeah he might not have
been the first Trump with the first
brand yeah
then run for president Regan might have
been the first star Trump was the first
brand but he was definitely a bigger
star than Reagan I think easily bragging
is before our time it's hard to
understand what it was like when he was
a movie star yeah I don't know it's
called Betty White and after that he's
still alive still kicking live Megan do
we have do you like do you have these
people's numbers general I don't have
her number
okay haven't seen Betty and
you become famous you get on rolodex
here's Keanu Reeves baby wipes some
famous people where I text him and I
call him just like this so strange like
I feel like that
mmm Steven Tyler's a weird one from
Aerosmith yeah yeah next each other in
mine alright that's the most surreal
feeling of sisters Wow it's weird I
never get used to it
no it's humbling though yeah but that's
why I always say I don't I don't do [ __ ]
I got no way I'd talk we would have real
talent right up to growing up Dennis
Pryor - some people like about you is
that you recognize that in yourself yeah
you know you're not you're not oblivious
to that you're not delusional people
listen they want to know that you know
you can't play musical instruments a or
do something crazy well don't they want
to feel like reflected like often often
at times I think that your audience
resonates to you like that it's like you
are asking a lot of times the questions
that they would love to ask the you know
people yeah when I when I listen to you
I hear somebody who's still a fan I'm
curious I'm curious yeah I have a
curiosity about things yeah and and I'm
not afraid I don't know [ __ ] I don't
have yeah I don't I just got some
experiences I'm not a expert at nothing
everybody that I sit across from his way
smarter than me
yeah and I'm fine with that let's have a
conversation I want to learn that's good
that's not that's what that's probably
why you're successful it's the way to
think world people be like oh I can't
believe you would say dude you would ask
Elizabeth Warren about her Native
American answer did you see that bro
Rachael's by now - but did you see the
interview with him and Elizabeth Warren
yes we pulled her out on the Native
American [ __ ] but you know here's the
weird thing about her it's like I don't
necessarily think she told the truth in
that interview and
know how she get away with it when she
said that the Boston Globe did an
investigation they said that she didn't
she didn't in any way profit off of that
or have an advantage she got here she
got hired for it from Harvard and she
wrote Native American on a resume like
they hired her based on her ethnicity
yeah yeah she's a liar yeah that's a lie
yeah which is fine listen I don't have
no problem with my politicians lying
they do it all the time but I want you
to acknowledge your line hold yourself
accountable like none of this [ __ ] is
disqualified it's not the 80s anymore
it's not the 90s where [ __ ] like that
ruins you just be honest like look I'm
American I've cheated before I've taken
shortcuts I [ __ ] used to put the
cheat code in Mike Tyson all the time
just to get Mike Tyson to skip everybody
else that's what we're based on yeah so
if she did that at some point her life
was it a horrible thing to do absolutely
make it a table for her make our
terrible present forever no I buy what
she was saying though that she was told
that she was Native American because
many people were and then they find out
when they get a DNA test it's not did
not happen to you didn't help you yeah
well hasn't been disproven yet but yeah
what are you Native American yeah I was
like growing up around the time I was
going to college my guy the work of my
dad found out that he he had filed the
paperwork to his college ten years after
the fact and got a bunch of money back
and so my dad's like well we're Native
American that's what we've been told our
whole time so we're trying to prove it
all right it's birth certificate and
whatnot and it's really hard to because
they didn't keep a lot of information
back then right so I put it on a
application got into Ohio State that way
cottham and it was real weird when I was
in like the minority home they just
liked on the orientation day there was
like they gave me a letter to say show
but this like from a hard-working
charity kid did it in good faith I had
no idea and it was the first time just
like when I sent in my application and
it was like what's your race I was like
I just found out I'm a Native American I
guess so I'm gonna put that and no one
check no one asked that's hilarious that
people know just ya know I didn't know I
was doing anything wrong the wild thing
about that is like that that
conversation is like people ask me why I
said that I'm like I'm just too dumb to
know that that wasn't a question I
wasn't supposed to ask you were supposed
to ask that
was that when a conversation the idea
that you're not as ridiculous that's a
huge thing we need to find out how she
reacts to the fact that she told a lie
the rest of her family is the did that
[ __ ] up the whole lineage right this
whole whole family's thought tearing
[ __ ] down off the wall like oh my god
we're not made of America how many
dreamcatchers were in the garbage that
weekend holy [ __ ] just feather sticking
out a hefty bag what she learns that
then the whole family after realized
that we're not Native American I had to
[ __ ] up some family you had to [ __ ] up
some tradition too
oh my lord there's a lot of people that
were shaking their head after that one
Josie actually got the DNA tests ok can
we talk about how [ __ ] up Ticketmaster
is real quick yeah you
I just figured I just put my mind
together on this thing yeah as a taxi
sent me oh my god take it my fat model I
take it master we're gonna take them all
down okay so take a master you know the
place where you buy tickets look I had
no clue about this Ticketmaster thing
I'm just starting to do some theatres
and [ __ ] on the tour so I'm starting
look at like what they charge to do like
the processing and servicing right you
buy it's like a thirty or forty dollar
ticket I looked at yours forty our
tickets $16 in servicing for a service
charge yeah is it per ticket per [ __ ]
ticket forty percent are they gonna pay
for [ __ ] in a venue like no I don't
that's the venue cost that you also got
to pay yeah it's just to process the
ticket and if you want to pick up a
we'll call another three dollars it's
unfathomable right so I'm starting to
think I'm going okay so cook for the
first time in my life I'm like okay I'm
I'm selling some tickets everything's
good and I'm just getting peace of the
door so I'm happy right and my boy who's
like this genius [ __ ] kid Oh Jay
Nigerian all these Nigerians are
geniuses and he comes up to me he's like
okay but what about the processing fee
for tikka miser how much are you getting
off of that I go what it was like what
percentage you getting off that I got
nothing he was wait but you're bringing
all the ticket sales
why aren't you getting a piece of that's
40% of your ticket price and I'm like
well I don't know and he goes and what
about the data from the tickets being
sold are you getting that I go no he
goes hold on so they're [ __ ] you and
getting paid to [ __ ] you I go what do
you mean he goes the game is data now
any business is successful right now is
all about data acquisition right any
business and data is not how many
followers we have on Instagram because
they could take your account away in a
second how many subs do you get on
YouTube because they could throttle your
search we could see
happen all the time it's direct connect
to fan right and what Ticketmaster has
done is they're your ticketing site they
get your email they get your data set
they get all your fans they know exactly
who your fans are and they email them
and tell them when you're coming into
town or when somebody else that they
might like that like you exactly and
then they're getting paid an absorbing
amount they're [ __ ] over the fans on
it so I'm like I'm talking to him and
he's like yo we got to just create
another one of these we got to create
another system that gives all that data
to the comic why does the middleman even
there we could create a way cheaper
ticketing service that gives every one
of those emails to a comic and it's like
comics used to do back in the days by
putting the comment cards on the tables
and you collect them afterwards you
could have an email list for every time
you go to Idaho an email list for every
time you go to New Jersey and email list
for all these different prices but most
authors do and Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
that's how Kevin Hart came up Kevin Hart
was going into all of these comedy clubs
and he was getting everybody's
[ __ ] email people wonder why
whenever Kevin would launch on these
social media sites he'd get all of these
crazy followers immediately it's because
of that road work he put in in those
comedy clubs anybody before anybody I
think louis c.k did that as well we had
this massive email and now you have
direct connection with your fans yeah
and that's what your fans want your fans
don't want Ticketmaster telling them
that Led Zeppelin's coming through they
want to know when Brogan's comes through
but you know Pearl Jam tried to fight
them back in the day what they have they
have exclusive deals with certain venues
they are top to bottom
yeah they own so they own Live Nation
and Live Nation owns a venue so they're
completely vertically integrated so if
you want to play at the garden or
whatever the hook it is right yeah so
you go we're gonna process your tickets
the only way you do is perform here is
you do it with our promotion company
which is like the nation and you're
gonna have to use our ticket processing
fee and and our venue they actually own
the venue's now but here's the thing
there's a handful you guys that get to
play those venues now I think with
podcasts now shows our 300 people
there's gonna be thousands of comics
that have 300 fans and the venue where
we perform is not imperative that it's
this specific one it could be a comedy
club it could be a hall it could be some
conference center it could be anything
it could be Airbnb but aren't you only
going to your math than when you're
doing these bigger venues well sometimes
now that they're Live Nation they own
some certain clubs
I work with Live Nation so now all your
[ __ ] is that so same stand-up yeah
really yeah why not just do the podcast
live every [ __ ] way different man
it's insane
yeah I like podcasts like this where
it's just people talking yeah yeah you
do it differently when you're playing
for an audience it's performed for them
and it becomes just weird ideas an issue
it just is not a it's not the same it's
not a real conversation like I think the
intimacy of podcasts one of the things
that people like about as I listen in
their ear right there got a little ear
plug it's like you're talking to them
yeah like you're right there when you're
doing it live it becomes a different
thing there's a rabbit it's a bad thing
yeah but it's a different thing but
stand-up is way better way it's just way
more fun well I'm saying is what are we
doing with this right it's like like you
shouldn't you should have a direct
connect all your fans
I should have Direct Connect all my fans
right we should be able to even the
venue should have that as well
why why do we why are we giving away all
the data yeah to a company that's really
not I know my agents gonna call me right
after this thing's gonna be like why the
[ __ ] we have to [ __ ] up so you want
their email you want your audience's
email a bit and that's what the audience
wants and I don't want my audience to
get charged 16 bucks every time they buy
a ticket where does that money go like
it costs $16 a ticket 40% of the ticket
price why not just create an email and
when you're at these venues just put it
up on the jumbotron and be like yo email
me after the email me at the show I mean
that's yeah that's one more step or we
could just create the ticket process in
the charges on way letter less scuse me
and and already starts aggregating the
emails and then if you want to get real
crazy with the view of a boy of yours
that like let's say my buddy Akash right
there do a podcast with it's like hey
Akash you're about to go on tour yeah
why don't you just use my data set man
they're gonna know you from doing a
podcast with me maybe you could they'll
want to see you it's like we get to
empower each other through that [ __ ] am
I making sense or it makes sense the
thing is specifically about data about
the email listen about they get that if
you show up in these different places
they get the email address because
that's how people get their tickets what
you get that you get the option of
saying because they'll ask you they'll
say you can Ticketmaster reply to you or
can Ticketmaster send you the latest
updates and news and yeah you can click
no yeah like I and I could
that's Ticketmaster but you would click
yes if it was us and there was somebody
who you are invested in going to see you
just don't want to take a master
promoting random offense depends would
you send me your email address and might
sell it absolutely yeah
even if you just click no like you do
want updates from Ticketmaster you're
not saying is it okay if this company
just starts selling my email address
because that's what they do that's what
they do
yeah bro they own us anyway but they
don't have to I'm saying now like
everybody that's coming out to your
shows is coming out from this podcast
they're not coming up cuz at
Ticketmaster and if you use a different
email service or ticketing service they
would come out with that one there was a
Sam Harris podcast where he talked about
this where they had on this expert they
were discussing how data is it's like a
commodity that no one knew was a
commodity and we signed off on it before
we realized it these people that don't
provide any service are getting that
data and it's worth billions of billions
of dollars which is essentially what
Facebook is it's Facebook but is so
shaping the way we communicate with each
other because the things that attract
people are conflict right so the things
that get you to engage are conflict
right so that's the stuff that shows up
in your email yeah they for your
Facebook for you they find out what's
gonna annoy you
yeah and that's the [ __ ] that the show
okay Wow Oh Jay has 800 thousand 500 two
[ __ ] days overnight instantly on
Twitter which nobody grows on Twitter
anymore no but at least at least Twitter
at least at least Facebook they're not
charging right my issue with if
Ticketmaster was like hey here's a free
service we just want to get your data
okay alright boom cool Facebook gets
jobs you wouldn't are you gonna [ __ ] me
in my ass and make me pay you
mmm I think Facebook gets charger they
just not show their ads yeah yeah but
they also like think about it they're
they've stolen a lot of that data from
people yeah a lot of ways for that is a
charge could you sign up for something
but you didn't know you were signing up
for that I know I was giving you all it
is what's weird to me man is [ __ ]
when you're talking about something and
then those ads show up in your Google
feed bro
we were just talking about coolers brah
and I looked at my Google news feed and
there's ads for coolers like how does my
phone know I was talking about cool
that's why I said they want us you know
what else is crazy
Haley's getting your car and you look
down at your phone and it says 32
minutes to wherever the [ __ ] you're
going
that happens to me all the time you
knows where you're gonna go it knows
your phone it'll be like thirty two
minutes to to whatever gym I go to art
that now he used to tell me forty
minutes to work in the morning now it
says forty minutes to Starbucks bro I'm
like I drink Starbucks every morning and
there's a Starbucks by my job in the
building but that's way it tells me how
going I'm going every morning i watch
one video of Robbie Williams you know
that like English singer hmm it was a
YouTube video with him and Tyson Fury
one I just clicked it was two minutes
long every other ad on Instagram is
Robbie Williams life so it's not good
the targeting isn't perfect yeah I'm not
gonna buy those tickets but my point is
it's Gary one YouTube video and then a
completely different platform yeah and
this is all within the last decade they
figured out how to do this yeah even if
we unplug with still plugged in if we
were all to delete everything that we
have on social media right now they got
us all ready bro that's why I don't like
all that snapchat [ __ ] with the face
filters and all that I did you see what
they did to him what'd they do to you
I think this was not made a complete
deep fake with they take they basically
took all the recordings of me talking
and mainly say words that I've never
said before it was it talked about me
sponsoring a hockey team made of
entirely of chimpanzees and a bunch of
other crazy [ __ ] that I might actually
say but it said it I've never said those
things is my voice with artificial
intelligence they've all the sounds that
my mouth makes and they use it with all
the right inflections and they create
these sentences Jay Pharoah is out of a
job they just passed the legislation
about that about deep fake yeah the
congresswoman from Brooklyn I can
remember her name she just passed the
legislation about defects they also did
video of the Mona Lisa talking bro they
got the Mona Lisa they took the painting
of the Mona Lisa and started now she's
like opening her mouth and saying things
they get with Abraham Lincoln and how
can you believe anything you can also
shemitah anymore yeah it's gonna be in a
few years you're not you'll be able to
now
you don't know what straw was naturally
and nobody cares about the truth from
the lies more in a tea that's better
maybe now we could say [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and beg from be fake what are you
talking about definitely deep think well
it's you're already getting porn with
actresses they're taking actresses face
and putting them on porn stars and you
can't tell oh yeah oh you can [ __ ]
everyone yeah and now they're gonna be
able to do that with virtual reality so
you're gonna do our porn yeah they have
that yeah vr porn and they put something
on your dick so it feels like yeah they
could put a little one of them little
things that jerks you off oh it's cool
you like your palm yeah I just started
[ __ ] listening in the audible books
because I'm old go I like flipping the
page write a book I just don't listen to
audible only because of of time purposes
and it's like it's like listening the
long-form podcast I'm like you know what
[ __ ] I'm still getting the
information and I feel like at this age
I retain information more by hearing it
right so I'm not about to go start
[ __ ] virtual reality [ __ ] so here's
the [ __ ] that's not porn but could be
interesting have you seen the one about
the basketball games what okay so they
put a few cameras so you can sit front
row but in VR oh I don't think I will
mind that that's the best looking around
you're seeing all the people that are
actually there in your front row at the
game last month I went the UM hates the
bathroom I went to Disney I went to
Disney and I went to that [ __ ] that
avatar avatar twice yeah me too
that [ __ ] was incredible and you know I
got anxiety right so I'm on it and I'm
like holy [ __ ] until you just remember
I'm not even moving right and then it's
just like it settles everything for you
and then you can just enjoy the actual
experience and that helped me I mean I
was telling my therapist about it cuz
that helps me when I when I'm dealing my
anxiety because it's like you know
breathing exercises things that get you
back to centre
even though you're falling and you can
feel the the the dragon breathing on you
instance like when you realize you're
really not moving
it just brings you right back to centre
then you're okay then you're fine you
can't do that on a roller coaster no yes
it's real but if they have a roller
coaster with virtual reality
look if you
wearing virtual reality goggles and they
put you on a row of Muenster yeah but I
can enjoy I can enjoy the what you mean
like they put these goggles on okay and
then while you're on this rollercoaster
you're experiencing things that aren't
really there but you explained like you
like going through wormholes and you're
traveling now you're seeing things
happen and I'd have a heart attack
that's not something I want to
experience I'm glad you talked about
anxiety I'm glad you talked about the
way you do because I think you've opened
it up for a lot of people I think you've
get you've made it a subject that's okay
to talk about for someone like you
mm-hmm
like a cool guy it was a smart dude who
is successful and talks openly about
anxiety and about how it's affected you
that's I think that's a you're doing a
very big service for that I didn't even
know what anxiety was until 2010 because
growing up in the environment that I
grew up and I just thought all those
feelings were normal I thought all those
feelings of paranoia you know being
anxious all the time like you know and I
used to smoke weed so you know you smoke
weed and you have a panic attack you
just blame it on the weed yeah I
remember driving the Burger King one
time with two of my homeboys one of them
is dead now his name is Terrell rest in
peace I'm out my man Zeke and I was high
as hell and my steering wheel needed
like steering fluid so it was shaking so
it was shaking my legs and I'm bugging
out just driving the Burger King a two
mile ride I'm like yo what do y'all got
a drive we're all gonna die right now
take the wheel right now I'm gonna crash
this [ __ ] car tripping the [ __ ]
out and they looking at me like no don't
let this [ __ ] smoke no more but
I had nothing to do with the weed it was
read probably accentuated though no
definitely did because when I have to
you know when I find out what anxiety
was in 2010 and I didn't stop going to
get you know corner therapy ants are
like two years ago cuz back in 2010 when
I when I got diagnosed with my first
panic attack that somebody the doctor
was saying hey this is a panic attack I
had just gotten fired from radio for the
fourth [ __ ] time and I was back
at home living with my mom and like 31
years old with two-year-old daughter and
you know collecting unemployment checks
so when I'm having this panic attack and
I go to the doctor and he's like yeah
your heart is fine you got a perfectly
fine heart and you're healthy you got an
athlete's heart he was like yo are you
stressed about anything I'm like [ __ ]
yeah
you know so in my mind all I got to do
is get me another job get back in
position and everything will be okay
yeah
but when you get back in position and
you know you've made more money you've
ever made in your life and you got book
status selling and TV shows and all of
this other [ __ ] you still having no same
panic attacks you like what the [ __ ] is
going on pressure that's it that's
exactly what it is pressure you think
you're gonna lose everything it's also
you experience pressure that most people
will never experience because you
experience pressure at this this public
scale it's not just pressure it's
pressure with people's eyes on you
and expectations and criticisms and all
these different things that the average
person is not gonna experience that for
millions of people and you do and it's
just like it's always on if you're one
of those crazy [ __ ] it reads comments
good luck at first I used to enjoy cuz I
was the guy who came up on YouTube
looking at all these WorldStarHipHop
conspiracy theories about people and
you'd be like oh my god mother [ __ ]
sacrifices hamsters and that's how he
got successful you think all that [ __ ]
is cool until you get old and you start
seeing things about you and you you
laugh at it at first
right until you realize like I not he
really starting to say some wild [ __ ]
what was the craziest one that you heard
about you I mean for me you know what it
is when they tried to meet to the [ __ ]
you try to get him out of here you know
that's that was that was the most that
was the wildest one to me because I was
always the president I say Livia truth
so nobody can use your truth against you
alright so it's not like they brought up
anything that I hadn't spoken about
numerous times before I written about in
my books they just decided to attack oh
yeah
it can happen it can it so that for me
that was like hi this is going too far
but then it's like you really can't do
anything about it that's the other thing
like there's there's no way to fight it
once the two phases out of the tube
there's no way to put the toothpaste
back in the tube yeah so only thing you
could do is just either let it consume
you and probably ruin you just because
you took it all in
you just keep it the [ __ ] moving like
you how you have to be confident enough
to know what's the truth and what's not
the true yeah and so now you don't read
any comments anymore I don't go on
Twitter at all Twitter is too toxic
that's it
oh yeah we're in verbally abusive
relationships with our [ __ ]
smartphones yeah I agree
yeah it's not it's definitely not
healthy you know we were talking about
it yesterday me and
Duncan Trussell we were saying that it's
like your diet like your diet if you
take in junk food all the time but eat a
bunch of shitty things that are
unhealthy it's not good for your body
well your mental diet is important too
if you're always taking in these toxic
arguments and yeah I mean half a Twitter
is just people screaming at each other
they're just yelling and insulting each
other and trying to find ways in this
person's being shitty or wrong or
negative and it's like that's not real
life no the real life that we experience
that were designed experiences like this
people interacting with it reasonably
it's one of the reasons why I think
people like podcast so much especially
good podcast where people have real
conversations is because you go oh okay
this is this is this is Vitas resonates
with me yeah whereas Twitter does not
resonate with Twitter just gets you
anxious yes you upset yes conversations
where people are actually being nice to
each other in person look I don't do
podcast over Skype I don't like it I
don't want to see you yes I want you to
be in the room and I want everyone to
know we're gonna be okay you know when
you when you have these conversations
and people listen to them like just one
on one like this or two on one but this
this kind of like what we're doing now
yeah this makes sense to people yeah
that's one of the reasons when I when
I'm out and about and you know like I'm
at the airport and somebody comes up to
me and talked to me I speak to him yeah
cuz I feel like that interaction was
supposed to happen right yes you know
what I mean normal Twitter Instagram
I ain't posed to be talking to you on
this [ __ ] yeah we're not supposed to be
human beings are not wired to be that
wired no everybody should not have that
kind of access to you know so it's just
like we got is we got to take back to
see the facade fall apart when you
respond to one of their tweets like
something big
[ __ ] you Charlemagne you ain't [ __ ] and
then you come back why in the bag I'm
just playing bro I'm a fan I didn't
really know what he said he's always
that they're just react could I in my
mind if people if you like somebody
right you see them you're gonna go up to
them and speak to them I just try to
gauge things on how I would do it right
for example I was on a plane with Steve
Nash this morning okay Steve Nash I'm
like my she's like oh she wipes my boy
he's like oh [ __ ] that Steve Nash and
I'm like oh [ __ ] that Steve I didn't
speak this deep did you say hello no
nothing no okay I didn't feel it
you're not respected right no he's a
great player
I feel John Stockton that's a little we
have to say hi to say what some people
you have to say hi to Rachel Dolezal
Seattle absolutely where was she shoes I
saw her with uh I think she had at least
one kid maybe in other words she's just
at the airport we're online
no TSA PreCheck sexual now she's bought
yet you bisexual biracial she's oh no
she's not biracial transracial she is
black that's both transracial I know but
what I'm saying is she's bi so she's
straight and gay what the thing yeah but
I said hello said what's up amazing
forehead one of the best forehead you'll
ever see in the game my one order that's
what I would even order you want to get
the selfie no I saw Jessi Smollett pics
room oh my goodness in Lafayette bakery
what do you think is gonna happen with
them nothing it's amazingly go I think
Chicago is coming after all no you think
so no didn't they say that they were an
item for the money for the money there's
no such thing as canceled coaching no
more canceled coaches absolute [ __ ]
o oj simpson proved it you know like
when Bill Cosby comes home he'll be on
the road doing [ __ ] stand-up or
Kelly's still out his selling shows like
Charlie Sheen is still out here
flourishing like Charlie Sheen ducked at
all wait a minute not all he did get
that some say the greatest endorsement
deal Magic Johnson ever sign
I'm saying we're not gonna act like his
career didn't flush bro it looks great
take this AIDS you go against a movie
theater I was in my car the day they
announced on the radio that Magic
Johnson had HIV and I was [ __ ] my
pants I was like oh my god this is like
the beginning of a zombie movie we're
all gonna get it if Magic Johnson with
all his money and all his fame if he's
got it I'm gonna get it we're all gonna
get it I was terrified
just all I remember in my car driving
yeah and then I hear it on the radio
Mike holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] this is insane thirty years
later he looks great he looks amazing
it's great he's on TV telling us why he
left the [ __ ] Lakers a night of
the Lakers not once did somebody say yo
you imagine got HIV that's all I was
thinking about every time see because he
looks incredible
he does look incredible look incredible
yeah it's not even positive and tests
anymore wait what yeah I heard that yeah
if you give him a test for HIV comes up
negative because apparently these
protease inhibitors and all these
different things that they take - huh -
the different medications
you don't even test positive for HIV
anymore by the way
listen it was this older white dude and
I forgot what TV show I was on the set
of but he was explaining to me uh-huh
the whole situation with magic and he
was like the reason that they chose
magic was because they wanted to erase a
lot of these stigmas people thought that
HIV and AIDS was a gay disease and they
needed like a alpha male I guess the to
have it to kind of erase that stigma and
to let people know that you can live
with it like HIV nights they gave it to
him whoa
this would he told
telling you somebody told me what they
said to me was magic I got caught up in
some type of scandal underaged right
yeah I'm a foot in before the scandal
was came out because the person that he
was wit was like some allegedly some
bigwigs
child or something like that and so they
said this is what you're gonna do so we
don't ruin you mr. Joe before you take
this in he believes in Sasquatch believe
Sasquatch was real that just started
right now on this podcast if I asked him
yesterday he did 100% I'm not saying I
believe that magic theory I'm just
repeating what I was oh that is a common
rumor that's out there I've heard that
I've heard that rumors right that he
doesn't actually have it but that it was
either that or but we just got done
saying how you read rumors about you
that are ridiculous and you go what the
[ __ ] and then you realize oh this is
what happens people just make [ __ ] up
and then people repeat the [ __ ] that
people make up cuz I can't fathom that
he beat aids bro aids was bodying people
back in the day like mercury Freddie
gone yeah who else
easy-easy e my downstairs neighbor yes
downstairs neighbor no no I had it down
for 30 look at him yeah book Charlie
Sheen for 350 bucks book him where I
cameo oh oh a cameo sunglasses on like
what is happening here what is what is
he doing
yeah this is that he aged very quickly
it's like see he seemed to be fine when
he was doing two and a Half Men when he
stopped doing that show he gauged like a
hundred years old he had HIV we don't
know how its effects - I forgot exactly
everybody everybody's not Magic Johnson
here okay
I'm saying that by the way that is why I
say magic is like the greatest NBA
player of all time
what because of that he played 13
seasons in the NBA went to nine NBA
Finals won five of them one in college
came in won his rookie year and went
one-on-one with HIV and [ __ ] one
destroyed he destroyed the stigma of HIV
definitely did anybody that catches HIV
right now the first thing you're gonna
say to yourself is give me a magic stuff
I can live through anything at Magic
matey yeah he's okay and by the way
what's worse herpes all over your dick
for life not that it comes back and
forth but it's always there the open
blisters forever forever or having HIV
definitely their herpes it's worse cuz
HIV they could basically cure it mady's
are pees on your dick forever meaning
those blisters don't go away
you can't even [ __ ] it'll hurt no way
nobody's saying that you get it dude a
type of like real hardcore herpes they
never go away they're just always they
have one that doesn't go away now
hypothetically would you ever see the
Damon Wayans bit about magic when magic
came back to the NBA no no nobody wanted
to block him oh yeah but Dennis Rodman
Dennis robbers like [ __ ] y'all spit in
your mouth and accelerate a goatman he's
one of the greatest of all time enough
credit is we had that we had to actually
delete a Damon Wayans joke from The
Breakfast Club because I used to play
like you know you know you have that
plays the loop yeah I had to delete it
wants to meet - times up Erica can you
say it
I mean I'll say it yeah yeah Damon way
Damon Wayans was on The Breakfast Club
and he was talking about the Bill Cosby
situation he just goes yo man have you
seen the women that are accusing Bill
Cosby they're all under a pible Damon
Wayans that there's like you know I mean
for the fences
always have she doesn't give a [ __ ] man
to bite what we do so that's it for
somebody else where's Dennis Rodman said
I'll spit in your mouth and accelerate
your symptoms bro
think about what Karl Malone think about
Karl Malone everybody right now Karl
Malone will get so much flak for this
what do you say but in the 90s what he
said made sense Oh none of us really
knew what hiv/aids walleteer everybody
said would you say Oh about playing
basketball with him like what if I hit
him in he starts bleeding and he gives
me like but that was when a lot of
people were thinking sure how could you
be mad at him for not knowing for being
angry about mosquitoes remember that yes
I do what about mosquitoes I mean yeah
that's reasonable though right I think
works with Ebola and they can give you
earlier or some [ __ ] or malaria why
can't they give you some HIV wrote
reason to be we've to be is somebody
said you can't get it in your mouth I
thought that's what propaganda like you
can't get it in your mouth when someone
comes in your mouth did you just put it
up all the mosquitoes are carriers of
yellow fever dengue fever Japanese
Emperor and sinful itis encephalitis
there's no evidence of mosquitoes can
transmit HIV studies with HIV have shown
clearly the virus disappears the
mosquito after about one to two days
yeah but what if that [ __ ] bites you and
then bites you bro look at that last
line I've never heard it described like
that the time required for them to
skeeto to digest a blood meal Jesus
Christ the only one talk about vampires
like that the blood meal so that means
if they get someone who's got HIV and
then they get to you within one to two
days doesn't that seem like it would get
you well
that's all I'm saying it's it's a
reasonable thing to ask these are
reasonable things now I have to worry
about you like that I'm married
well the real fear is pandemic diseases
how about the game yes [ __ ] we're
talking about you're on the beach and
influence and dude with the Charlie
Sheen's next to yous bitten spitting in
your mouth yeah just some tiger blood no
Charlie had a moment a moment moment
when he should know sound - I don't
believe you winnin bro dude you know I
don't matter the difference between
magic and Charlie I don't think Charlie
was ever cool to anybody because we Alan
wanted we wanted to be magic at some
point in our lives everybody want to be
Magic Johnson's live show know what
fixed at those Russell Peters fixed that
what Russell Peters fixed it because he
went with him so what what happened was
Charlie was trying to do it by himself
and really didn't have anything to say
and people get bored after a while they
would boo him and like he was like oh
[ __ ] you I have your money and he's like
a bunch of dumb [ __ ] cuz he tried to do
this live tour but he didn't plan it out
right so then we did is he brought
Russell Peters with him so Russell who's
the best at work in the crack life he
could just make something out of nothing
right
so Russell just got him to talk and then
Russell would start talking [ __ ] and
making fun and someone would say
something Russell incorporate that and
Russell treated it like a comedy show
and turned it into something that was
actually good I see him live
Russell's there so it's gonna be good
because Russell's the right Russell's
gonna handle it and turn into funny
Charlie just did a podcast yeah yeah hi
Cass back then and nobody cared about
podcast it was early have some stories
oh dude oh yeah those crack stories in
the doors
be willing to tell him though oh he's
telling you I've already got AIDS what's
worse well you remember when he was on
television he was talking about just
smoking rocks yeah so all this and the
people like what yeah what are you
saying
but did that excite people in 2019 like
we've seen all the crackheads no back
then it was the right window of time
yeah it was like him coming through and
just being unapologetic about doing
drugs and and you don't pay huggers to
[ __ ] you you pay him illegally if you
kind of [ __ ] him saying it was
unapologetic and that's why it resonated
and that's also why no one could get him
with like a me-too thing it's like but
he gonna say course he'll tell you what
he did first of all no woman is gonna
say he slept at home you're sure yeah
maybe he did that to protect himself if
you just got AIDS
real quick says every time the girl
leaves the house oh by the way positive
oh she's really nice to them they like
him they don't want to [ __ ] him throw
him under the bus some some guys are
likely old like that Drake no I don't
know about Drake Derek Jeter Oh Gina was
giving out gift bags baby yeah you know
saying can you imagine the number one
that came out he was giving signed
baseballs yeah think about how many guys
have gotten a signed baseball from their
girlfriends as a gift think about what
was going through their heads when they
read the post that moment and there's
this sign Derek Jeter baseball dude no
other girls might have but he was just
nice to me he's a gentleman but what you
gotta earn that gift back Oh Joe what
Joe saying is very true to that's why I
always it like when I see dudes still
treating women like [ __ ] in 2019 like
get [ __ ] him and kicking him out the
room oh my god I'm not answering the
phone for after foot I'm like you're
wily you should be treating her with the
utmost respect and being extremely nice
cuz you just never know
uber she's your friend oh yeah she
should be
yeah she should be your friend like I
don't understand why guys like I say
this long time
laughs they were calling women [ __ ]
summer [ __ ] [ __ ] I like it in a
positive way like check this bad [ __ ]
out yes that's okay some of them are
just old school [ __ ] though there's
some [ __ ] where it's like you're
saying in a derogatory way like you
could say it in a positive way you're
laughing about it or you could say it in
derogatory way yeah sometimes I'll say
in a derogatory way as a man yeah 20 19
no what about [ __ ] I'm W that ever
what about [ __ ] now I've never used [ __ ]
he got in trouble for using the word
[ __ ] I did in trouble yeah trouble you
get but you got outraged yeah yeah I'm
gonna ask you this first of all I think
what you're doing with YouTube is genius
it's brilliant you're the first comic to
really capitalize on using you to you
know Netflix do you want to give you a
special look [ __ ] I don't need you let
me do this it'll get more views and it
has and it's been amazing it's been
beautiful to watch but are you
experience of the popularity increase
are you experiencing some pushback on
some of your material because you go
hard
well the weirdest thing no it's like
we've curated an expectation for it mmm
so the people that are going there are
waiting for it it's not people who like
got free tickets right a funny bones
website I know what you do think they're
there for it they go there and watch you
talk about eating ass to eat an ass I
was just talking about this one on a pot
on the other day but like you're just
talking about how privileged you have to
be to eat ass because think about all
the third world countries but they can't
even eat food we're so full in a minute
Republic you can't have a [ __ ]
cocktail or it up without almost dying
you think they're eating ass in American
we're so full we got so many choices
that we choose to eat ass dude for fun
yeah but bro I'm telling you they're not
it's pretty pretty amazing they're all
leaning into it and I think that people
have had enough with the PC [ __ ] so
they'd really like to see the fact that
this is out there and I mean we're
posting you know I'll tell you one thing
the Joe Rogan effect we used to do a
million views a week on my youtube
channel I came on here two million now
doubled that's crazy
double I'll see what happens now why
maybe we'll see it was nothing
Charlamagne effect in there well we do a
pocket I mean but the channel exists
because of the Charlamagne effect my
channel
we're putting the brilliant idiots about
videos idiots videos out every week on
the channel like without him that
channel doesn't exist I mean like you
two guys I swear to god have the biggest
influence on the market and it's like he
gave me this opportunity to have all
these people view and I was able to put
the stuff out and luckily they liked it
but the same thing happened here we just
doubled up again I mean it's crazy that
it's all dependent upon generosity and
being a fan cuz that's what I do
I mean when I'm talking to a scientist
or talking to you yeah I'm a fan yeah
I'm interested I'm curious and it's not
like you're putting on some [ __ ] [ __ ]
right now say like Andrews funny he's
been funny for the exact years so now
everybody else is actually realizing
what we all knew already yeah and the
limitations of like those platforms
putting you on like Netflix or HBO or
something like that that doesn't exist
anymore
and it's not you you're not playing your
whole game like you know that you go you
go getting those systems and they teach
you out just to shoot three-pointers
yeah you know saying instead of like
[ __ ] cultivating your whole game
that's why you know ruining it I love
Britney it is I tried not to promote
movies I know it sounds crazy right
Nobuko this is interesting good and the
reason I do is because I love our
audience I love that group of people who
come to listen to us every week they
know that we just out here saying some
wild [ __ ] not even on purpose just
because we're we're trying to get ideas
out and we're just talking through
things it's when you bring those
Outsiders in who here you don't know any
context to nothing take that little
piece out of context give it to the rest
of the world now the rest of the world
is outraged we and that's got to come
over here any [ __ ] way right we want
to be wild we want a place let's talk
about that because where do you think
that's going like the way is an outrage
culture reached full outrage it's coming
back we turned it around I agree I'm
turning around you know what made me
think about that two situations in the
past two weeks okay remember the first
one but the Whoopi Goldberg one from
yesterday with Bella Thorne
I didn't hear when Bella Thorne she took
some nude pictures somebody was gonna
expose him so she just shared him
herself first so I think somebody hacked
her out hacked her cloud somebody like
your cloud they're trying to say hey
we're gonna put this out unless you give
us money or some [ __ ] she's like [ __ ]
i'ma put my own [ __ ] on Twitter yeah so
Whoopi Goldberg gets on a train it will
set of juggernaut my name is it lovely
Whoopi gets on the viewer what
look it's 2019 when you take pictures
they go up to the cloud
hackers can hack you so don't take
pictures yeah she's like it's just
common sense like it's not it's not
worth it just don't take the pictures
hey I was like oh your victim shaming
but I thought that I thought that was
what the outrage was gonna be it wasn't
it was like oh [ __ ] whooping you're
talking super common sense now Bella
came out and said she was being a victim
shame but the general public on social
media was like so y'all oh man it would
be for talking common sense and I was
like oh [ __ ] if you can't say its victim
shaming if she's correct because we are
moving into an era where all information
is gonna be available to everybody I
think that's that's gonna be a thing
that we're gonna have to overcome the
privacy is going out the window
done it's not gonna exist anymore like
what our expectations of privacy are so
much different than people that lived in
our parents age well our kids it's gonna
be even less and then their kids non
exist they didn't even know FDR was
crippled that's right FDR was crippled
yeah see they didn't know he would
literally hold himself up at the podium
I think he got polio or some [ __ ]
right so he was paraplegic right and but
the press respected his role as
president and they respected his privacy
I mean he had side [ __ ] he had all
this [ __ ] going on and he was just stand
up at the podium holding himself up
whenever you were talking everything
else besides that they kind of roll him
around but the people didn't know cuz
there wasn't this access oh I want us to
get back the line each other think about
it used to be a time where you didn't
know what somebody's religion was we
didn't know what somebody's political
views were like you didn't like nobody
knew like you just went you present it
and you went the [ __ ] home
I think we need to get back to that well
I think it's too much [ __ ] so
every small truth get back in the closet
not just with your guys just what else
get back to [ __ ] me today
yeah just get back to bullshitting each
other because guess what remember I used
to say you don't want the truth cuz you
can't handle the truth that dis era the
world cannot handle truth that's why
anyone tell us about UFOs what we think
is happening with UFOs they won't tell
us that UFOs exist because if they told
us that UFOs exist [ __ ] would
probably go crazy when the reality is we
really probably need to know UFOs exist
because it would humble the [ __ ] out of
everyone well that's the only time we
get
or right like in every movie right the
only time Russia and China and America
get on a conference call is when bro
movies aliens are coming up the movies
Ronald Reagan said that in a speech in
the 80s Ronald Reagan told Mikhail
Gorbachev why to [ __ ] a we beefin
because one day we might be we might
have an extraterrestrial threat and then
we got to come together and everybody
was like what the [ __ ] is Ronald Reagan
talking about look quickly we would put
aside our differences we were three
faced faced with an a threat from an
alien world and everybody was like what
does he know yeah I would respect I'm
gonna find out tonight I would respect
your prejudice if aliens came hold on oh
my god okay all right hey you know it's
true if I you know it's real it is real
I really don't have no choice but to
respect you mmm Johnny we're I think
we're getting to the end of outrage I
always culture I think he was almost
over we had we put on a clip this last
week of there was his kid in the front
row in a wheelchair heckling me and went
back and forth and initially I put it
out like a [ __ ] what's gonna happen am I
gonna have these like you know people
rolling up to my shows and like [ __ ]
polite you handled it really well he was
also a special kid yeah he had something
you know people have it you remember
around people and they just have a
[ __ ] yeah like they have a clique you
know who has it
ari Ari Ari Shaffir he has this [ __ ]
I don't there's something I just when
I'm around I just like him I just kind
of wanted to tell me his opinions on
[ __ ] he's asked him yeah how do you feel
about carpets and he'll just [ __ ]
tell you how they I'm dumb whatever so
it's like he just had this thing needs
such positive energy and I'm making fun
of a guy from [ __ ] being in a
wheelchair and he's making fun of me for
having a shitty upper body and like
literally I go to him I was like I said
you know your upper body's pretty good
and he goes what's your Excuse
like quick and we had this moment and no
backlash yeah the thing was cool no
backlash should matter
except for the guy in the wheelchair
right if everybody else is like wow a
lot of [ __ ] are you picking on him the
guy in the wheelchair don't care and the
guy in the wheelchair is going back and
forth why the [ __ ] are you just never
people that have it and there are always
parents of people that have things like
when there is this person has a seizure
and in one of my videos everybody who
had seizures was cool with it it was
always a parent of a kid who had a
seizure who was like my son suffers from
how dare you wouldn't a clip up like
that so it's always a fence on behalf of
because I really think that people who
suffer for things they went through way
harder things in a joke yeah and they
actually like that they're being spoken
to as a regular person in the audience
not babied like every other part of
their life when can I get the door for
you can I get it yeah yeah it's like
they all right for the first time I'm in
it I don't pose I won't poster like make
jokes or talk [ __ ] about something that
I wouldn't want to happen to me or
somebody I love though right I can
handle right you know saying yeah like
hiv/aids I don't want it I wouldn't trip
to I mean it's not what we used to think
it was so it's a different thing
yeah do you know what bug catchers are
yeah that's a book around [ __ ] people
who have they try to get it yeah there's
a bunch of guys the gay community we're
trying to get a chariot yeah that's like
a crow yeah hold on self load they're
people that wanted to get HIV and this
is back in the day where it was a death
sentence there was a lot of guys who
were doing that hold on their goal their
goal yeah they would try they would put
out ads like Craigslist looking for
hiv-positive guys to give me the bug
this is why cults happen cuz people need
to be part of something there it's like
in them some people are just broken
exactly cuz I heard about that 20 years
ago and I thought that was crazy but not
and I'm thinking about it I'm like what
was their life like yeah I need to know
what their life was like if they had
something to lose the day was actually
successful would they be doing that yeah
I didn't know what kind of people were
out there trying to catch dis bulk this
every every step in the spectrum of
crazy you you think about it and there's
a whole [ __ ] category of people that
are doing that so bug catching was one
of them like it was a big thing
guys were like actively going out and
trying and guys who had HIV we're trying
to go give it to people yeah that's why
I did thing with Kama I don't even
necessarily believe in calm anymore
because every day of our life we're
trying to avoid crazy right yeah but you
can't you know say when a guy comes in
with a gun and he shoots up a
[ __ ] school yeah like what are
we supposed to do we didn't do anything
to cause that but he's got something
going on with his life right that caused
him to snap and it affected us like if
you're walking down the street and you
know a guy's just angry about something
he bumps into you and you're like oh
excuse me [ __ ] you mean excuse me and
he's ready to fight I don't got nothing
to do with you
right I've got everything to do with him
so you really can't avoid this crazy
yeah exists I had a conversation with
someone they were talking about like
everything in your life you have
manifested and created I go okay explain
babies who get shot in drive-bys or shut
the [ __ ] up yeah there's random things
that happened yeah kids get leukemia
what would they do something bad yeah
come on I use it's bigger than you
that's a thing with people hated him we
are a very small part of this big
[ __ ] ecosystem right we really think
that everything in our life is that
important that it could affect the world
get the [ __ ] out of here some Chinese
random factors why cuz you know you
think about the secret like the law of
attraction your thumbs become things I
think the thing that we forget about
that is not only do our it's not just
our thoughts it's our actions you know
I'm saying it's not like you're just
sitting around you didn't think you
didn't sin trying to think about doing
this yeah you actually put in some
[ __ ] work that's the difference
between the secret and reality is that
people think that you think things into
existence but no when you're successful
and people say what did you do well I
thought this into existence it's show me
how you did that well I got up every
morning at 6:00 a.m. I [ __ ] hustle to
the gym and then I wrote jokes all day a
you go Lizzy [ __ ] did this in the work
yeah yeah but in the work it's like it's
like literally if somebody says you hate
one day you're gonna win the lottery so
you're gonna sit at home right all day
waiting to win the lottery get up and go
to the [ __ ] store and buy a Powerball
ticket you know I think Chappelle had
that joke he's like you don't think
they're starving kids in Africa thinking
about food nice roast beef sandwich I
ain't coming exact now don't get me
wrong it's plenty of things that I've
thought about that I've manifested but
like you said I took the steps to go put
in the
like his focus there's a process
discipline I got this theory called
putting the weed in the bag you know I'm
saying and it came from the movie belly
because neither DMX was sitting at this
table with these two young kids and they
were bagging up the weed and all the
kids like I got thinking money what
y'all got to ain't get money and team X
is like put the weed in the back first
then go out there and get money you have
to go through the process yeah so I can
start with a thought yeah you still
gotta execute hmm put some [ __ ] work
in I remember I was talking to this girl
she was a friend of a friend of mine and
she was telling me how I found the
secret and my life is gonna be amazing
now and I'm gonna I'm gonna get married
and I'm gonna meet the right man never
does okay and then I ran into her like a
year later she came to one of my comedy
shows and I'm like how's everything
going she's like I don't get it I've
been using the secret she was a
sweetheart of a person but she really
believed that her life was gonna
transform I'll never forget the
juxtaposition of those two conversations
that's why that's why the positions that
we're in and media you have to be very
responsible with these positions Malcolm
X said that Malcolm X said the person
who control the media controlled the
monitor the masses so you have to be
very very responsible well I remember
when you used to get a lot of flack for
putting on just different voices that
people who didn't agree with yeah why
are you giving these people a platform
platform I'm like yo everybody deserves
to be heard yeah I guess something not
everybody but just I want to know how
people think too I want if I don't agree
especially people you don't again the
conversation isn't a cosign and I think
that's what we we often mistake well in
this day and age to was especially on
the left as so many people are talking
about deep platforming you know 2d
platform people I don't like they know I
thought I don't like that you might get
either I thought people getting mad
Allah volleyball this week you know I'm
saying cuz the comments he made the
molle on ESPN which I didn't he just was
like she was like hey let's shift gears
like you can shift gives me any time but
we didn't he said it just like that you
should bring news I didn't say you
nitwit was a placeholder right if she
had said hey let's switch it up he would
say hey you switch but every people's
like already need to stop putting them
on ESPN I'm like wait a minute huh
literally just last year y'all
he was the drunk uncle at the picnic
right you love him or hate him he's good
entertainment but that now because he
said that you want to take him off and
I'm like we got to stop doing that
because guess what every single one of
us is going to say something that is
going to offend somebody at some point
yeah yeah that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't have a platform I'm not
calling for nobody to get killed it also
makes things fun when people say stupid
[ __ ] 10 times you know when Stephen
Smith was going off about and ruies
winning the title it was like butter
bean this is a disgrace there was man
like the guy is speaking the way he
would speak if you were around him yeah
do you got appreciate that unless you
want everybody to be Ryan Seacrest you
should [ __ ] apprecia not there's
anything wrong Ryan Seacrest but you
should appreciate someone who's just
given you what they really think
yes why don't we do that's why he's so
popular yeah we pretend to hate it right
but the reality is we're gonna keep
listening the secondly it's a ruse also
attention a lot of people that's some
America feeds off additional Trump is
president yeah that's what the crashes
are still viable was the first family
okay drama every year every year they
find a new piece of trauma no [ __ ] gets
calm and cool the show ends so they need
a new piece of drama Oh whoo you got
cheese on this here who's gonna have a
baby
you gonna need a baby but whatever it is
every year eight you're gonna chop your
dick off but you know respect her for
with Kim she is getting people out of
jail she's going for it I can go back
before they I respect the Kardashians
because if we really really pay
attention to the Kardashians over the
past ten years first of all you got to
put them up there with some of the
greatest dynasties of all time this is
Lakers this is Patriots this is [ __ ]
they've made billions yes billions with
a B so yes so many social conversations
have started because of the Kardashians
you talking about interracial
relationships you're talking about the
transgender thing you're talking about
jobs mental health with condoms
yeah plastic surgery they did change the
shape of American women they changed
absolutely
they changed essences they made that
whole fat relocation thing popular they
suck it out of your waist turn your
waist in this little thing and turn your
ass into this ridiculous platform look
before okay Kim but Kim learn that from
black women though good people forget
but that's a pile of the women that you
would look at someone who really has it
yeah it's different yeah you will see a
woman who has a big ass naturally it
looks like it belongs on yes it's a
different thing yeah yeah yeah they have
thick legs right they're there they're
[ __ ] genetically superior built like
a turkey they built sexy Kimber's
inspiration you know people don't
remember Kim came up in the black
circuit right she did King magazine and
smooth that's right he that's right
that's right Wendy Williams radio show
orally oh that's what I'm better I'm
better when I was doing radio with women
he knew her before she was ever on
anything when she was who's who's
assistant some of this is Paris organize
closets for Paris Hilton I got an old
picture like me and Kim from like to the
Avenue different yeah
but I will say she always had that
vision she used to always say I'm gonna
do what Paris is doing times 100 Wow
mother [ __ ] did it
the secret because it used to be the
kiss of death of a girl did porn that
was the end
Lisa and yeah she was the one to break
that down well what's it to her jenna
jameson
I think jenna jameson was the first one
to become actually popular outside of
porn oh I thought you meant like the
first person to break like the racial
barrier employ oh yes you want therapist
she was the first to bleach the racial
but I mean doing porn periods oh yeah
that where you could be up where you
could be a celeb outside and you talk
about radio it's not too many people
that came up off the Liberty sex tapes
between that really popped off yeah who
made it office acts do you remember when
girls were jamming obviously they were
showing their [ __ ] on purpose just
happened to be down with [ __ ] did you
not know that camera was down near your
[ __ ] they set that up that's a lot of
confidence today were climbing out of
your cars showing their [ __ ] yeah not a
lot of which fingers Joe what is
happening
that's all the more reason you got a
real MK bro that girl that was hopping
on a cause and you could see her vagina
sex tapes is out here getting prisoners
free is doing that I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah I don't know the [ __ ] if she's best
friends with Donald Trump yeah right if
you care about prison reform care about
criminal justice reform yes you should
be happy that these people are getting
out yeah if you're worried about oh
she's doing it in the White House with
Donald Trump the guy who just did 15
years right
nothing cares what President Lincoln
Mauser and what she doesn't have to do
this right she could just be buying cars
and getting her nails done she's
choosing to spend her time to get these
people that are unjustly accused and and
convicted and get them released and that
and Trump like him or not he's listening
to her and he's helping her and that but
you know why because he's a celebrity he
understands the angle yeah so you keep
saying all these politicians to talk to
uh celebrities yes that [ __ ] goes over
his hey you gotta send another celebrity
to get in his ear yeah cuz he understand
that type of line he understands their
power he understands where their reach
is he knows that Kim K doing something
is way more valuable than some random
you know Democratic Congress person well
you're seeing that so much now you look
at Capitol Hill the past few weeks you
see you know I was there meet me TI and
David gross was there talking about
opportunities on legislation I was there
with taraji talking about bringing
social-emotional learning in schools in
therapy you had a time he see Coates and
Danny Glover was dead as week talking
about HR 40 you had john stewart there
talking about the victims of 9/11 now be
compensated by the way the 9/11 [ __ ] i
don't even know that was going on bro if
jon stewart hadn't done that that would
i would have never even known that was
going on and that is [ __ ] up and it
was a simple statement the people you
said you would never forget you forgot
anybody can get that you can be with no
teef sitting in [ __ ] South Carolina in
a trailer park you understand if you
understand that like Jon Stewart doesn't
have to do that it doesn't do that
because he needs to it's in him yeah it
gives you a different sense of purpose
yeah like that's what really means
something when you talk to me about
talking about anxiety and mental health
like the past couple years I feel like
I've been walking in my purpose you know
because I truly feel like if we can get
more people to deal with their mental
health issues you'll reduce so much of
the other bull
[ __ ] we complaining about in America the
violence the gun shootings because when
you got a bunch of people who have never
dealt with their trauma I never dealt
with their pain and their hurt hurt
people hurt people
yeah and all we do is go around
redistribute in that pain the others you
think murderers and rapists do that she
could put it thrill of it no they are
broken damaged people so they go and
break in damage other people yes
so if you can get people to deal with
their mental health issues man that's
the foundation of it all to me that's
the real secret getting through to that
[ __ ] yeah there is a thing about about
purpose that like what happens I think
when when some people reach financial
independence and I mean like [ __ ] you
money meaning like you don't have to
work anymore your family good everything
that's good yeah you have some people go
well I'm gonna get even more money and
I'm gonna become a billionaire and a
trillionaire whatever and then some
people go I'm gonna live life instead of
survive it or if you're working every
week so you can get a paycheck there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that
doesn't majority of people are well you
are surviving yes it that that that job
is no different than being out there in
the forest trying to find some foods you
can either get some shelter you get
financial dependents you have the
opportunity to truly do whatever you
want every single day with your life yes
and some people go you know what I want
to do I want to go to [ __ ] DC and
help out with these causes or I want to
put on a whole comedy community you know
I mean and like you really put it on
your back I want to help other people
out I want to have these conversations
and just talk [ __ ] about you know
[ __ ] magic have an HIV whatever it is
we're actually choosing to do the things
that we enjoy because you realize what's
important like you know when you're
talking about something like
opportunities on legislation I feel like
that goes hand in hand with mental
health because the environment is so
important so if you can you know get
into these these communities these poor
and disenfranchised there is and you can
start putting things in these
communities that people actually need
like in the hood you replace the liquor
stores and the [ __ ] chicken spots in
the check cashing places which you know
juice bars and mental health spas and
you know wellness centers things that
people actually need now you're creating
an environment where people can thrive
in instead of just trying to [ __ ]
survive in yeah you know saying you
can't properly deal with your mental
health you trying to survive every
[ __ ] day but I think what you're
doing is very important is you're
bringing up that conversation that
conversation wasn't taking place before
the mental health conversation about
xiety amongst cool successful people it
just wasn't happening
everybody was pretending everybody was
there they're hiding from it you keep
secrets like yeah you got the float tank
and you [ __ ] compound yeah you
telling people about it oh yeah okay the
reasons why that thing became popular
yeah I I got one in 2002 Wow yeah I did
they for the first time like two weeks
ago yeah man if you go to some float
places they'll ask you how you found out
about it it's like did you find out from
the internet yelp and then they'll say
Joe Rogan that's why I wanted the
because I talk about it so much as
videos I mean I gave one away
I gave one oh I had bought a new one I
said I'm gonna give one away and I just
got random emails and I picked one of
them had it sent to this guy's house had
it set up I just because I wanted people
to know about what these things are
I've never felt stillness like I felt
inside a floatation yeah that's amazing
and it's like you know at first you'd
like okay we want you to get butt-naked
you know and you know the [ __ ] going
you know saying and then you're like nah
that's computing a lot of confidence in
your [ __ ] I wasn't even swing an idea
I'm a grower not a shower my [ __ ] is
like no bro I can't be sorry I actually
would try to make it a little chubby
just in case you can't trust these
peopie don't know record me in this [ __ ]
so the lights went off and it's like
when you first get in its allowing
yourself to relax because at first
you're fighting it a little bit you got
your head up you like I don't know from
a drown yeah when you finally just relax
you know you don't even know what
[ __ ] I won't win right and I've never
experienced the level of students like
that it was point it was period where I
thought I was actually I'm like I'm
alive right now because your eyes are
open but it's totally done it's totally
ducts you don't know if you're really
sleep and you don't know feel the water
you don't feel the water you don't know
if you're in and out of consciousness
it's it's - it's Wow everybody should do
fluid there yeah guys what is the
hardest part about having influence
that's a nice pregnant pause I was dope
right then the clock was going like
well-timed yeah I don't know what's the
hardest I don't think about it that way
I think it's you're very there's it's
very there's very few people that you
have the opportunity to have the kind of
influence that you or I have or you it's
it's it's very very strange I think
you've got to realise what harm you can
do you got to be careful and the kind of
things you say are the kind of things
you promote you know the kind of things
that you sign off on or agree to and I
think there's also a responsibility to
tell people about cool [ __ ] tell people
of things that have benefited you to
help tell people about how you've
overcome your own personal mistakes I
think all those things are very
important yeah I never I never even
thought about having influence until
like the past three four years because
you know I'm just out here doing my
thing just doing it but then when you
really when you realize you are having
influence and a lot of that influence
could be negative yeah that's when you
realize like oh [ __ ] let me make sure
I'm doing the right things with these
platforms you know I mean let me make
sure I'm bringing on the right voices
that people can learn from let me make
sure I'm telling people about the things
in my life that are making me a better
person
so for me it's like the best compliment
I get nowadays and people say man you've
really grown like you've you've really
evolved like like as visible people can
see it yeah that right there lets me
know I'm putting out the right energy
into the equals yeah and also people
become inspired to seek that same kind
of path when someone in the public eye
like yourself and they see you grow and
expand and change your views on things
it also inspires other people to open up
themselves and change their own
perspective and enhance their own way of
looking at the world yeah I said a lot
of [ __ ] up watch you're going live on
the air you're not reading a script
right no you're free balling it's gonna
happen Annie and I think the worst thing
that can happen too is like for me you
know Breakfast Club has only been going
off in nine years so I never had
experienced this level of attention and
you know you start reading things
about yourself in the media like you
read real articles like oh the hip-hop
Howard Stern and I'm like oh so I got to
be like Howard so I gotta get more that
[ __ ] so what Howard dough right cuz I'm
giving a little bit at night how would
do y'all know so it's just like you can
get caught up in that ya know you could
get caught up in what people's
expectations of you are yeah change you
know a lot of people say that happens to
certain comedians they become their
character dice dice yeah I was gonna
bring up his name's Andrew silverstein
dot the dice man whose character yeah
that he would do in his bit he would do
he was doing a routine where he would be
John Travolta he would do a Sylvester
Stallone and then he would do this
character called the dice man and that
part was so funny and so good it took
over his whole act yeah I went
toe-to-toe with dad one time toe-to-toe
yeah on Wendy Williams Show back in the
day when I was Wendy's a sidekick and
you know Wendy vh1 Wendy had a show on
vh1 and Andrew Dice Clay had a song on
vh1 so they bought him wanting to
promote it and like we just ended up
going I don't know why the [ __ ] me and
it was happen on each other yes and like
vh1 edited it to make it look like he
like kind of [ __ ] me up but they kept
a couple of mine in he was really upset
like I called him I said you like a fat
Fonzie [ __ ] living I'm like oh [ __ ]
it's on it's on laugh at that I thought
it was funny
I would've been allowed with that if I
looked like a fat Fonzie bug Oh
[Music]
continued terminate a model
but what you said is real good I never
want to become a character chill my yeah
yeah and I feel like it was a certain
point in my life where I was becoming a
character of myself and it's like that's
not real like you can't claim claim to
be a real person and be out here
pretending to be real you either really
you not yeah and what's real is yo being
honest about going to a therapist what's
really being honest about your mental
health issues was really talking about
being a father like that got real [ __ ]
like yeah you can't always be try to be
cool yes that's not cool that's fake and
that only existed when there was like
some sort of your pride projecting
something you're putting something out
there in these small bits when you're
doing what you do and you're talking for
hours and hours on got to be you got to
be you you at the end of the day it's
gonna come out whether you like it or
nothing anymore there are and people
with the longest careers I feel like are
the people who evolved born time right
yeah you could see the guys who have
real growth like Howard Stern in the
beginning when we really think about
Howard like chicks were queefing on
speakers oh yeah that was a normal thing
in a Howard Stern radio show is come in
who has the loudest queef on the speaker
they're lucky that Tiffany Haddish
wasn't around back then
oh it would be over a cannon sound it
doesn't make sense
she's like large [ __ ] midgets into the
[ __ ] atmosphere well yeah she used to
do that all the time she would quit
[ __ ] what she's shameless doesn't
give a [ __ ] that the equivalent of a
guys do [ __ ] like on comedy Letus
approach to commie it's quite
interesting somewhat be like didn't he
likes bars he says he likes jokes he
doesn't like school [ __ ] mmm still
[ __ ] if it's the right bit can be
funny really it has to be the right it
has to be a real comic with a real
reason to [ __ ] that stool there has to
be something to it trying to think Eddy
[ __ ] this tool bro
see I like Eddie I like Richard I like
Chris Rock bless you election well you
know I'm saying I like that I like those
guys that actually don't say just say
something yes like have something and
have something to say louis c.k has
to say yeah like I want I like people to
have something to say all that stool
[ __ ] is the thing and I want to get
him on stage I think he could do it oh
you never I would never disrespect the
craft like that well you wouldn't have
to disrespect it you just have to want
to do it and then try it yeah I don't
want to do it I think we do it for fun I
do it if you don't want to do it don't
do it but you could do it I tried one
weekend and my first joke was like you
know what I'm gonna sit down cuz I don't
want anybody else say Charlotte means up
here trying to do stand-up maybe don't
try it just did three hours let's bring
it home hey Andrew Thank You Brendan
Schaub I really do appreciate what you
do for comments though I know because
I've seen what you do for Andrew and
Jesse made Peluso and Miss Pat Donna
Riley he's people that really [ __ ] with
so thank you for that my pleasure it's
for me it's I'm honored that I have the
platform to be able to help all right
bye brother peace
there's so much fun
[Applause]
[Music]